evansko tous les plus grands tournois
d'échec il se déroule en présentiel ou
en ligne vivez comprenez en direct les
parties des meilleurs joueurs de la
planète avec les commentaires en
français de nos experts notre moteur
d'analyse l'explorateur d'ouverture et
les tables bases retrouvez toutes les
infos essentielles comme le programme
les horaires des rondes les prix les
résultats les comptes rendus quotidien
les bio des joueurs les règles des
partages et plus encore vous pouvez même
participer à la compétition en
pronostiquant les résultats pour tenter
de gagner des abonnements premium alors
rendez-vous dès maintenant sur
chess.com/avent ou c'est bien sur le
site internet que sur nos applications
iOS et Android pour vivre votre passion
comme nulle part ailleurs
[Musique]
bonjour à tous c'est à toi qui n'a pas
envie de dire bonjour
à tous
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le stream
de cheesecom avec comme invité
aujourd'hui encore Fatou
donc ça la rentrée du Nord-Ouest on a de
beaux de beaux appariements aujourd'hui
à vous montrer Fatou magnifique
ils sont affichés à l'écran donc on a
ici avec les Blancs Magnus Carlson qui a
pas encore remporté une partie qui va
juste contre un lireza Firuza
on espère que sa première victoire ne
sera pas aujourd'hui
français donc bien sûr on va essayer de
soutenir à diresa en cette partie c'est
une Sicilienne d'ailleurs on va la on va
la regarder c'est quelques instants on
va voir ce Wesley contre apopov on va
avoir karwana contre Google on va voir
Nakamura contre ma média Rohff et guéri
contre Paris donc on va revenir
à la partie qui vient tout juste de
commencer et avec E6 Fatou
qu'est-ce que tu penses que ça peut être
comme ouverture bon là
sicilienne E6 on sait pas encore ce que
ça va être
tu penses que Magnus va opter pour une
c'est ouvert
une surprise avec B3
non je pense qu'on va rester classique
j'espère
comme ça ce sera un petit peu animé et
je fout des trois waouh alors
OK
alors bien entendu
alors j'ai parlé de B3 à tout à l'heure
parce que je voyais bien Magnus faire
une surprise
mais par contre tous les trois c'était
pas ma marraine je sais pas du tout
pensé
et alors les trois c'est un coup bizarre
pas tout
mais qui a du sens alors qu'il y a du
sens moins chez les débutants mais qui
en a finalement après on a l'idée de
jouer avec C3 et
reculer le fond c'est de c'est bien
placé de pousser après Descartes pour
récupérer le centre comme ça
mais c'est vrai que là tout de suite on
se dit que ça bloque juste nos pièces
qui vont pas sortir donc les billes il
va mettre pas mal de temps à sortir
l'autre fois en CE1 il va mettre un
petit peu de temps aussi
ouais alors si vous débutez et que vous
nous regardez
de manière générale ne mettez pas les
fous devant les pions comme ça dans
l'ouverture parce qu'après ça crée des
embouteillages lui il bloqué par lui qui
est bloqué par lui etc et en fait tout
le monde est au final tout le monde est
bloqué et ouais c'est
NON NON
voilà
donc mais bon là Magnus c'est ce qui
fait donc c'est un goût qui est
thématique d'ailleurs c'est un coup qui
transpose dans pas mal de lignes
regardez on a par exemple dans cette
position
D6 avec W5 échecs qui permet de
transposer dans une vente comme ça donc
là il y a plusieurs possibilités je peux
le C3 par exemple et sur A6 x 4 B5 ou C2
on transpose à peu près dans la position
que à New sauf que là la différence
c'est que les règles là je le si c'est
pas des 6 d'accord
mais le schéma des blancs et le même et
on a aussi cette position avec petit
rock qui est possible aussi et sur la 6
et ben les Blancs n'ont pas de bonne
case pour ce fou parce qu'après x 4
malheureusement je perds une pièce après
une P5 fou B3 et C4 le fou étant fait
attention
et si je recule dans ces quatre il y
aura encore B5 donc c'est pas terrible
et en deux je suis un petit peu mal
placé quoi donc fou des droits ici et le
coup principal qui a l'air hyper bizarre
mais l'idée c'est le joueur avec C3 ou
C2 et D4 et comme le dit aussi Michel
d'ailleurs qu'on salit dans le chat et
ben il y a une variante qui existe avec
avec du C4
ça paraît très bizarre mais ça existe
pas tout
et l'idée bien sûr c'est 14 souvent
on l'ouvre B5 d'ailleurs
on recommande ce qui
respecte des principes qui est plus ou
moins agréable à jouer mais après si les
joueurs veulent faire des folies
pourquoi pas
et après ces quatre ça se joue aussi il
y a enfin on l'a vu pas mal à la mode
c'est une sorte de marozzi on sait que
les normes vont pas manger bien
évidemment parce que ça aurait trop le
fou mais un coup comme B4 par exemple on
met le four en C2 et le plus tard on
pourra jouer avec des trois ou des
quatre alors je suis pas du tout un
expert de cette position mais je sais
que ça se joue pas mal et d'ailleurs
Carlsen a beaucoup joué le chemin avec
ces quatre
donc c'est pas impossible que Magnus
nous sorte un C4 plus tard dans la
partie donc là pas peut-être pas
maintenant ça a pas de sens on va
attendre d'abord que les Noirs ça
faiblissent avec B5 mais je pense que
c'est 4 ça risque d'être un coup
qu'on peut voir dans cette partie là un
petit rock
et écoute ben ça arrive
intéressante
[Musique]
je t'ai créé le truc et j'ai oublié ben
écoute Fatou
tu es très forte
merci de rien
je pense qu'on est on est pas mal
on est pas mal
et je vais réouvrir
sain et sans avec ça et ça voilà on
devrait être bon et donc voilà je vous
disais que alors ma question Fatou
est-ce que tu penses qu'on peut jouer
ici un peu comme dessin pour prendre le
centre avec les noirs
où est-ce que c'est pas pour rien
roquets pas les Noirs il y a encore au
centre après il est pas spécialement
danger non plus on va pouvoir sortir les
pièces devant
mais
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on nous en empêche est-ce
qu'on nous empêche vraiment de le faire
moi je pense que j'attendrai j'attendrai
si ça tenait qu'à moi mais ça doit être
jouable
tu vas me dire tout de suite ce que tu
en penses j'en suis sûr
ouais ben souvent en fait dans ces
positions
mais après puis on prend puis on prend
il y a tout revient comme tu l'as tu
l'avais dit la colonne ouverte eux par
le vis-à-vis roi dame est ouvert et sur
un comme fouette très souvent on a le
coup des quatre qui arrive et qui peut
essayer de créer au noir un pion isolé
après la les échanges des pions c'est
contredés et maintenant Fatou qui est
une championne du piano
voilà c'est une position dans laquelle
on aurait pu essayer de travailler mais
ici magou c'est un fou en détroit qui
empêche complètement
le jeu D4 maintenant il y a d'autres
idées ici à regarder alors j'ai pas du
tout envie de proposer ces quatre qui a
la convaincre vraiment très très moche
mais ça pourrait être des fois une bonne
version de la de la
mélodie après ces quatre mais je pense
qu'après ces quatre on a simplement
cavalier B4
a pas trop de cases où aller donc ça on
va pas du tout le voir donc si jamais il
joue des 5 et qu'on rentre dans cette
position je verrai bien un coup du style
fou et fin suivi des 4 atouts
alors oui
le souci c'est que
je vais pas forcément envie de me créer
un pion isolé moi aussi souvent sur ces
trois DK trop vite la prise et je
t'approche depuis des fois donc avoir si
jamais les noirs et ont le temps de
faire fout je sais pas trop pas dans
tous les cas des fois j'ai pas besoin de
faire ces trois les quatre parce que là
en fait les blancs sont pas en train
d'essayer de prendre de l'espace au
centre
les plans préférés F1 ils sont en train
d'essayer de de créer un pion isolé à
l'adversaire donc est-ce que je vais
faire C3 pour que je D4 je pense pas
parce que des fois c'est ça et ben je
peux manger directement c'est 5 mais il
y a beaucoup de position beaucoup de cas
où je peux jouer en fait fou ou trois ou
cavaler C3 pour attaquer les pions
centraux par exemple caresse3 je vais te
fou G5 et là directement je peux me
lancer de manger là et manger là et
après manger plein de cinq car j'ai les
mines le défenseur du pion des cinq
cavalier F6 ça c'était Matic et fou aux
trois aussi c'est pour ça que je suis
pas sûr que mettre depuis en C3 soit une
bonne chose si tu vois c'est pas
obligatoire
donc tout à l'heure c'était différent
j'avais un pion en 4 vraiment
c'est cool
mais si les pions s'échangent au centre
e.d j'ai plus envie de faire ces trois
des quatre je pense plutôt à faire
sauf si il faut évidemment mais moi je
te disais que je pense que je dois
mettre le fond à F1 d'ailleurs en F1
c'est pas mal aussi
parce que tout à l'heure on parlait de
jouer des 4 et de laisser un plan isolé
au noir mais une fois que j'aurais créé
ce premier isolé je pourrais peut-être
le mettre en mettre le fourrage à deux
taper un jour sur deux cinq donc mon fou
en G2 je l'aime bien plutôt qu'en C2 je
sais pas si vraiment il va faire plus de
boulot quand j'ai deux enfin ça à voir
où est-ce que le foot sera mieux mais
aussi mettre le pur en C3 ça me gêne
aussi alors des fois je flotte et puis
en C3 c'est vrai quand on a un point des
fois on va essayer de mettre le pion ici
pour bloquer le pion
les fous mettre le cavalier en B3 via
par via des deux et après quand j'ai
encada mon cavailler là mon pion là et
changer les fous et ben je peux mettre
un câble en deux quatre ça c'est une
belle idée pour lutter contre un pion
isolé mais après je sais pas obligé de
prendre ce
setup là je peux aussi jouer avec ses
trois ou trois pour forcer les Noirs en
fait à prendre ici et après la prise je
prends le cavalier et je mets une fois
range les deux et je tape sur le 5 il y
a plusieurs setups pour jouer là dessus
et le fait de le C3 très vite et ben je
suis un peu comique
parce que je peux plus
choisir je suis un peu de dedans et là
je viens de voir un coup noir attendez
je crois que je
viens de voir le coup fadou qui a été
joué je n'arrive pas à en croire mes
yeux
on a vu un G5
alors Ali Reza qui est complètement anti
je crois les gars
[Rires]
pourquoi pas les 5 alors pourquoi je te
réponds tout de suite à tout alors
salut à tous alors Fatou
alors je sens que je pense c'est à mon
heure à thé vert qui vient d'arriver il
adore ce type de coup c'est fou qui sont
farfelus mais ici alors sans regarder la
jauge j'ai envie de dire à la roche je
connais pas cette position exacte mais
j'ai envie de dire souvent que le
meilleur coup c'est H3 pour en fait
empêcher empêcher G4 alors il y a une
ouverture que d'ailleurs j'ai joué une
fois avec succès
j'étais un petit thé c'est un National 1
je voulais te perdre la veille avec une
position complètement gagnante t'as
aucun à Toulouse je m'en souviens très
très bien et le lendemain dimanche matin
j'avais les Noirs contre un genre à 2000
il m'a juste écart
j'ai fait aussi
image de cavalier F3
et j'ai fait j'ai 5
voilà et bon je le fais partie un peu
mais je connaissais un peu la pollution
et je savais que dans cette position bah
le meilleur coup des blancs c'est H3
parce qu'en fait le purgé il va être
affaibli
pendant toute la partie et H3 ça empêche
G4 et tu peux pas commencer à faire H5
on n'a pas sorti des pièces je peux pas
attaquer comme ça quoi et le meilleur
coup c'est H3 et moi l'adversaire ici
il a mal joué alors je me sens plus qui
m'a joué d'ailleurs mais imaginons un
truc du style de 4
et peut-être pas à 4 qu'est-ce qui m'a
plu
[Musique]
j'arrête plus à me jouer mais en gros il
m'a fait je crois qu'il m'a joindre le 4
et j'ai pu jouer en fait c'est 5 qui va
sS6 et au final j'avais une position
assez intéressante parce que j'avais
réussi à abandonner à mettre mon fond en
G7 il y a contrôle la gaz D4 avec le
pion ici il y avait un truc comme ça
avec D4 j'avais fait G4 puis on prend
j'avais réussi à très vite prendre
l'avantage j'avais gagné en vaincu mais
bon c'est pas conseillé je sens que
c'est un mauvais coup c'est un mauvais
coup et le bon coup c'est H3 ça réfute
la ligne parce que j'ai trop de
problèmes pardon de fou j'ai 7 cavaler
ces trois ou je pense que je joue mais
en fait tu vas jusqu'où tu veux mais
mais juste c'est un dragon avec plonger
5 quoi enfin
tu vois c'est juste un mauvais c'est
très très mauvais et voilà
donc là
dessus
en Détroit le blanc ont du mal à
répondre avec le Centre directement tu
vois
de ce blocus un peu enfin ce blocage de
pièces ce manque de développement chez
les Blancs pour pour faire quelque chose
que normalement on ne ferait pas
salut malin
mais c'est vrai que ici j'ai pas des
quatre qui pourraient être une sorte de
révélation et Michel aussi nous dit que
dans la rétige c'est vrai qu'il y a
plein de lignes qui existent avec du G5
pour dévier ce cavalier en fait de la
case centrale contrôle la casse de 4
et écoute bah en tout cas ça là on va
avoir une partie hyper animée et c'est
un peu ce qu'on voulait je pense
et
bon en tout cas c'est un cours original
les deux joueurs sont en tout cas même
mieux si leur papa c'est clair et fioro
je pense qu'il est à moitié
en train parce que bon je suis pas sûr
que ça ne prête pas ça je pense un peu
plus là hier on avait misé sur une sur
une prépa avec son cavalier
ça le promet une partie animée parce que
les joueurs ne respectent pas les les
règles basiques du déchets on voit qu'il
y a un fou qui plaçait en D3 il y a un
pion qui avance de 5
si on fait un site d'ouverture là ils
sont balayés
avec les noirs on sait que c'est c'était
vraiment avec les Blancs ça peut être
n'importe qui mais
mais en tout cas en tout cas c'est c'est
une partie qui est animée qui va être
sympa à suivre je pense parce que les
joueurs en plus
cartienne réputation d'être très très
bon dans les positions un peu égales tu
vois etc mais car c'est il aime beaucoup
aussi relever les défis quand la
pollution elle part un peu en cacahuète
et on a d'ailleurs beaucoup vu contre un
VL des fois des positions
hyper compliquées
adore relever les défis donc je pense
que là en plus il n'a pas gagné une
seule partie je pense que il va pas se
priver je pense qu'il va il va y aller
il a aussi pour jouer pour gagner et les
prix créatif donc je pense ça va montre
une partie
très intéressante à suivre en tout cas
la Carson Mac Carlson avec tous les
trois G5 au quatrième coup franchement
Fatou je pense qu'on peut pas rêver
mieux ça va être notre partie fil rouge
je pense
de la soirée
alors
j'ai bien dormi je ouais je suis je suis
en forme pas tout et salut Alicia salut
Alicia
le système non non si c'est pas du tout
un dragon
il a fait la Sicilienne avec E6 c'est
c'est pas du tout le dragon et après il
arrive G5 dans c'est plutôt G6 qui
conseillait dans cette position ou alors
Jacques des 5 comme on avait dit mais
enfin les deux jours en m'explique en
fait je crois les mec il voulait mettre
son fond en C4 et lui il voulait juste
et
donc ok est-ce qu'on fait un petit tour
Fatou
bah oui
elle m'intéresse énormément mais ok bon
la cadence c'est deux heures encore on a
beaucoup de temps je pense qu'on a le
temps d'aller voir un peu ce qui se
passe si on est reparti H3 notre retour
ou pas H3 alors dans cette position
peut-être pas
c'est un lot j'arrivais à faire des
quatre rapidement mais alors il y a
aussi une autre position d'ailleurs
avant de faire le tour dans la rue
solimo et d'ailleurs c'est une partie
qui a été jouée
c'est une sorte de Rosalie mot
tu perds un temps avec les Blancs
c'est hyper intéressant ce qui se passe
regardez partie qui a été joué dans ce
tournoi là c'était une ronde alors je
sais plus quel ronde Fatou c'était entre
Paris et Abdou santorov où il y avait eu
E5
cavalier C6 fou B5
et
c'était quoi la ligne déjà
non il avait joué pendant des six échecs
et la ligne c'était
cavalier 6 tours et dans cette position
je crois bien que
les Noirs avaient le tour J8
Fatou pour envoyer G5
et ça va être hyper chaud je crois qu'en
plus on tord j'ai 8
je crois que Paris avait joué B4
pour que je puis on prend et jouer à
trois en fait
bref et ça va être une partie hyper
compliqué c'est un truc comme ça alors
peut-être que je me trompe dans l'ordre
de coups peut-être que j'ai oublié des
coups mais c'est un truc comme ça je
connais aussi dans cette position
le coup j'ai 5
et je l'avais aussi expliqué
dans le direct que j'ai 5 c'est un coup
qui existe avec cavaler proche de 5 pour
G8 et en fait c'est assez chaud tu vois
et donc maintenant avec les ordinateurs
il y a plein de choses que tu peux dire
inventer ou
trouver des idées quoi donc il y a un
tour de qui existe il y a un resto qui
existe
et
mais tu vois que la pression différente
le fou il est pas en B5 il était il est
en D3 c'est Magnus et là dans la partie
resa et Magnus et bien le Caval est dans
C6 il est pas en
D7 mais il y a 5 qui a été joué mais
Magnus qui a quand même fait foudre
enfin tu vois c'est une potion à 530 et
là Magnus qui sur le 5 rejoue
tout B5
pour jouer une rousse au niveau
ou en fait
où en fait à lireza un jauge 5
donc elle reste à un temps de plus mais
il a une grosse 5 mais ce pion il peut
aussi utiliser pour Josh 4
mais le problème de G4 c'est qu'après
emprise
et que tu fais encore H5 en fait tu sais
qu'elle m'affaibli
normalement tu tu pousses pas les pions
ici trop vite enfin au cinquième sixième
coup c'est quand même
c'est ouf
Carcès il faut peut-être
il faut peut-être ça hein
c'est toujours en fait je comprends que
tu puisses jouer un peu funky pour
essayer de stabiliser mais là c'est
c'est un peu olig mais j'ai l'impression
car c'est bon
c'est un défi à relever il va être
content ouais ouais mais bon
c'est en fait c'est hyper établissant
parce que quand tu penses à tout ça tu
dis ok déjà les noirs n'ont pas sorti de
pièces
et le roi il va aller où
sur le long terme c'est dur je pense
qu'il y a pas bouger
mais bon franchement c'est à voir c'est
avoir curieux de voir la suite mais
j'aime pas trop ce que nous fait Fillon
c'est artistique
mais contre Magnus j'ai l'impression que
c'est
j'ai l'impression que c'est un peu too
much
malheureusement
[Musique]
je suis pas sûr que ce soit la bonne
idée ça va une personne
je mets une pièce sur Magnus oui alors
par contre ça tout j'ai un truc à te
lancer je vais vous mettre le
confessionnal Carven et pas ce
professionnel et je pense que c'est
intéressant de voir ce que Carson a nous
dire parce que franchement Fatou
ils viennent
en espérant que cette fois ce soit pas
sur la notation des coûts sur partie qui
là je pense que ça peut être intéressant
de voir ce que Carson pense du G5 Dali
resa donc on va pouvoir faire ça je vais
d'ailleurs couper mon bon micro pour
[Musique]
écrire c'est marqué personne
professionnelle donc j'espère que en
anglais si ça norvégien on va vraiment
chercher un norvégien pour traduire
parce que j'ai envie de savoir
donc Fatou
je voudrais le confessionnel de Mister
Carlson
[Musique]
bon je suis bug ça va former ça
je vous annonce que je suis deg j'aurais
pu laisser mais bon si quelqu'un parle
en norvégien dans le chat vous me dites
je mets la je mets la vidéo et et vous
nous traduisez mais malheureusement je
crois que que norvégien ça sert à quand
même je pense on peut on peut comprendre
[Musique]
alors j'étais curieuse là d'une
norvégien j'allais j'étais à fond dedans
si il y a un norvégien dans le chat ou
si vous connaissez quelqu'un qui est
norvégien s'il vous plaît
j'ai besoin de le savoir amener-le sur
le stream tout de suite et quelque chose
de d'assez horrible c'est que j'avais un
voisin norvégien il y a une semaine
je
vais vous remettre la la le
concessionnal pour Fatou qui va essayer
de te déchiffrer le Norvégien c'est
vraiment là c'est c'est un peu comme la
guerre froide vous savez c'est le
message ah à essayer de deviner
oui charpentier j'espère que norvégien
d'origine
les joueurs peuvent venir
peuvent venir
donner un peu leur état d'esprit ou dire
ce qu'ils veulent dire
à tout moment de la partie oh
professional voilà c'est c'est pas mal
ce qu'ils ont fait je pense
et on va repartir depuis le début
attendez
[Musique]
j'attends beaucoup de toi là
moi j'ai compris R
j'ai compris
tous les deux
je sais pas quoi à tempo derrière
et après l'improvisation
après il était mort de rire donc je ne
sais pas non mais en fait
Magnus je pense qu'il est content je
pense qu'il est content parce que c'est
une partie
c'est une partie marrante
et puis encore une fois il adore relever
le défi là dedans les positions bizarres
il adore les joueurs qui essayent de le
battre parce qu'en fait c'est vrai que
quand il fait un tournant avec beaucoup
de joueurs qui sert un peu la vis contre
Magnus parce que c'est le plus fort du
monde etc et c'est très dur de gagner
même quand vous avez les blancs contre
Magnus mais un joueur comme un lireza un
blanc noir Carson packardsen il joue
pour le gain et là on voit bien mais je
sens
et ça je trouve que c'est génial et donc
[Musique]
il est content je pense que je ne partir
il est content que la pollution
transforme de rien et il est content de
choses de manière générale mais après ce
qu'il a dit dans le professionnel je
n'ai absolument rien compris
je suis un peu déçu j'aurais bien aimé
quelqu'un me traduise un norvégien j'en
connais j'en connais un je suis content
je comprends c'est un tournoi qui se
passe en Norvège je comprends qu'il
fasse qui fasse tout son norvégien mais
mais voilà en tout cas sympa la partie
fumer 5 comment tu penses qu'il va
répondre à notre ami
je pense qu'il va jouer G4
[Musique]
il pense qu'il va jouer encore un coup
funky
[Musique]
il a fait une folie et juste après en
fait il s'est il s'est remis sur des
plans de base
est-ce que là il va je suis pas sûr
qu'il continue le fait avec G4 ou
quelque chose de surprenant je pense
qu'il va se développer
un peu plus bas alors après quoi
exactement
tout est faisable là j'ai 4 non déjà
oui j'ai hyper affaiblissant il faut le
faire plus tard j'ai 4 enfin
là je vois pas l'intérêt
à la limite à la limite fou G7 D4
je comprends je fasse ça pour chasser et
manger un pion je comprends tu vois mais
là j'ai quatre pour rien je vois pas
comme ça
il y a une rupture qui est une fois que
je sortais de la pièce etc il y aura une
rupture avec F3 et quand tu prendras je
prépare
c'est moi
[Musique]
merci et je prends aussi que en match
nul
on va commencer le Petit Paris
pardon je crois que c'est vraiment des
médicaments
il faut prendre les faut prendre ton
cachet on en parler hier
si vous voulez
c'est pas mal aérien
j'ai essayé plein de trucs mais à chaque
fois ordonnance
tu prends autre chose mais c'est pas
baisser c'est pas assez bien alors ça va
toujours toujours calmé
[Musique]
hello Alors donc Fatou avant de que
j'aille prendre mon petit cachet
assise paraît forcer
H6
c'est la preuve que ça s'est mal passé
quand même
il est bien défendu là maintenant faut
peut-être
se développer non mais je sais où j'ai 4
moi
même qu'il y a des cas je le vois pas du
tout le but c'est de faire G4 pour
chaise cavaler donc je change les pièces
et j'ai 400 plus rien quoi
tu dis que Magnus il va enfin annuler
n'hésitez pas dans le chat aussi à
pronostiquer vous avez sûrement être
meilleur que nous
alors hier on a fait zéro je crois
mais ce que j'ai ça compte
que la première
armée
comme tu veux
dis-moi ce que tu veux faire
en tout cas pour moi c'est parti
OK
[Musique]
Fatou oui Fatou oui c'est moi
sur
[Musique]
mais ça c'est Google
qui me dit que l'Armageddon de Nakamura
[Musique]
moi aussi
j'essaie de regarder un petit peu
elle est nulle
[Musique]
tu fais quoi
est-ce qu'on peut voir la partie ou pas
pour moi il y a aucun intérêt oui
[Musique]
ça c'est la partie de vent de Forest qui
est jamais V8
mais bon en fait ça
pas vraiment d'intérêt parce qu'on sait
que c'est une partie qui a été
voilà
ok nul
ok mais bon c'est d'avance
donc ton Armageddon dis-moi vite fait
tout
[Musique]
naturel
jouer par un Magnus
on va revenir sur la partie de Magnus
qui vient de jouer ici le coup G7
cookies
développa
il vient de se passer fouger 7 et
c'était mon idée
c'est bien j'aurais eu un coup
G7 là on peut commencer à regarder
clairement le comte 4
c'est en quoi c'est courageux et sur D4
des fois puis on prend C3 joueur de
Granby tu sais avec le pion G5 et le
fond G7 comme ça c'est pas sûr que ça
soit si bien
et
après on peut juste C3 directement et
des 4 mais Descartes dans les deux cas
G4 je sais pas
mais peut-être cavalier bouge je sais
pas trop où
comme ça qui se regarde
ça peut très vite partir
sauf qu'il a joué le piong c'est la même
position que la rossolino
quand même
à toi combien de points gagne-t-on dans
le tournoi par victoire et en cas
d'Armageddon alors c'est trois points la
victoire en cas de match nul on gagne un
point et grâce à l'Armageddon on peut
gagner un demi point supplémentaire
ouais
on peut parier vous pouvez parier avec
nous alors d'ailleurs Fatou on peut
créer si tu veux une prédiction parce
que je pense
hein
on peut pas maintenir c'est ça
dans le classique ce sera dans leur
magasin si vous pensez que que
donner le résultat de celui qui va
marquer le plus de points entre les deux
donc ça va être entre 45 et et Filou
et donc
tu le fais pas tout
je le fais je vais pouvoir parier
tu vas parier ben j'ai beaucoup de
points
120 moques
vont partir très loin très vite on a
vitesse de la lumière
je vous laisse
10 minutes
et du coup ce qui est intéressant c'est
comme vous savez que je vais faire en
ligne sur sur Carlson je pense que enfin
moi je vous conseille de miser filou
parce que vous pouvez gagner beaucoup
il y a beaucoup en jeu
allez qui va gagner des gens on va
plus personne pour
valide on va être bien là on va être
bien
alors combien comment je fais pour
parier
120 800 donc
la cote est énorme pour
parler sur
Envie de parier
[Rires]
120 Kanaks
diction
de manière générale on mange dans sa
position avec E6 moi plutôt depuis en B
mais là il y a E6 et G6 en fait dans les
dans les dans les renseignements avec
avec G6 comme ça je peux manger de g de
B ou de B d'accord
avec 6 c'est plutôt B c'est même B tout
le temps
si je prends là souvent il y a une idée
de jouer avec
pour jouer sur les cases noires contre
le fou mais ici c'est vrai que
j'ai 4 et cavalier bouge et vous prend
le 5
donc en fait ici on a l'impression que
c'est pas trop faire le 5 mais peut-être
sur le long terme ça peut être possible
et tout droit il y a quand même G4
donc je sais pas sûr que j'arrive à
jouer E5 sinon B prend qui a l'air quand
même beaucoup plus logique il y a aussi
plein de ventes théoriques où on joueuse
qu'on joue plein de choses comme ça mais
étant G4 qui me gêne en tout cas on va
voir une partie très intéressante
qu'est-ce qu'on va voir Fatou là ce qui
va jouer des quatre
T4 à l'air intéressant
les gens si vous voulez gagner de
l'argent là à Paris sur sur les raisins
vous avez la vous avez la prédiction qui
est dans le chat au dessus du chat pour
parier des points de chaîne
il y a 220
contre 2600 les gars
et franchement je vous conseille de
parier
là vous pouvez gagner jackpot vous
pariez juste 10 000 sur Ali raisin vous
pouvez gagner je sais pas 100000 quoi
c'est comme ça non
strueuse
normalement tu paries de testons ta
grosse quantité de temps contre les
jetons en face là je parlais tous mes
jetons contre rien en fait et si je
perche perds tout donc il y a pas de
lien regarde rkpm juste au dessus du
chat il y a marqué il y a un truc qui a
marqué prédire avec des points de chaîne
en espagnol moi donc
32 cas bah voilà voilà l'ombre de Marie
à suivez l'exemple les gens suivez
l'exemple
suivez l'exemple logique pour
pouvoir
trouver un peu de place aux cavaliers
aussi
de Magnus traduit
les derniers mots il disait qu'on était
il était content qu'il avait une toute
nouvelle partie au bout de trois coups
après tous les trois et je sens et qui
trouvait ça drôle
voilà regarde Fatou j'ai la confession
de Carlson on va la mettre
allez je vais vous la voilà ça va être
sympa
il faut il faut s'amuser un peu quand
même
tant qu'à faire
je pense que tout le monde tout le monde
tout le monde l'a voulu c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont traduite
parce que sinon bon c'est pas très
important quoi une confession
là c'est avec celle là
il y a pas mal allez on va couper la
confession 45 qui est traduite
par Fatou
c'est pas celle-là
[Musique]
à tout de suite
et nous sommes de retour alors
voilà donc en fait ce qui s'est passé
Magnus qui dit qu'il avait réfléchi à ce
que ally resa prouve je contrôle 4 et
tout mais il pensait pas qu'il pouvait
jouer aussi sur la société donc Magnus a
dit bon je vais improvisé et là je vais
foudre
et là il se ranger 5 et il dit que c'est
marrant parce que c'est une partie qui
est complètement nouvelle après trois
coups de jeu et que ben c'est une partie
où ils vont s'amuser voilà et puis les
trois Marius t'as dit qu'il
connaissaient quasiment rien mais durant
et puis essayer de s'amuser voilà enfin
tout ce que tu veux aller voir leur Mag
et donc tu vas commencer à l'instant
que les gens aiment bien c'est un petit
peu de
tes échecs
alors donc là vous avez pardon allez
ouais j'ai un peu alors
c'est logique enfin tout c'était de
fermer les cases noires maintenant que
tu as plus ton noir donc tu casses la
structure de l'adversaire et tu fais
avec des quatre tu vois je contredis
ça n'a qu'à il aime bien doivent gagner
la structure c'est enfin la cadence
c'est 10 minutes pour les blancs contre
7 pour le noir
et en cas d'égalité et ben ce sera
des Noirs qui passent et Fatou et
moi-même
avant parier sur Nakamura donc en fait
là on a rien en jeu pas tout
à Paris
je pense que
il vient en Pikachu
je peux en avoir
moi je peux le faire mais bon sur ma
chaîne je le fréquent peu importe mais
c'est vrai que le faire sur tescom je
sais pas si c'est bien de mettre en
Pikachu parce que j'ai le costume
Pikachu ce serait trop osé
le Pikachu de XL il fait du
génial j'ai fait un tournoi pendant
carnaval quand j'habite aux Canaries il
y a 23 échecs carnaval il fallait venir
habiller
quoi et j'étais déguisé en Pikachu
il y a un enfant qui avait à peu près 8
ans comme moi
et là et un ministre tout enfin mini
Pikachu et là j'ai dit peut-être que
peut-être que mon déguisement il est pas
propre
peut-être que je suis un peu vieux pour
notre Pikachu mais bon je m'en fous je
t'ai content que Pikachu
et voilà on a même pris des photos et
tout avec le petit c'est marrant quoi
je l'ai pas gagné je suis arrivé
deuxième
qui a acheté genre un masque c'est tout
[Musique]
moi j'étais vraiment moi j'ai vraiment
le jeu quoi j'étais vraiment déguisé
j'avais hyper chaud quoi c'est trop
chaud quoi
il y avait un joueur qui était là
c'était marrant à sergent qui avait 2200
Hello
et on savait que c'était pour rentrer
dans le temps on sait pas que c'était
parce que
[Musique]
il était déguisé tellement bien qu'on
voyait pas son visage on voit rien
et il est 3 ou 4 quoi donc on savait que
c'était un bon joueur mais on sait pas
combien il avait on savait que c'était
pas
donc l'arbitre qui venait il disait
enfin en fait voilà mais ça a été caché
pendant
pendant quelques rondes et après j'ai
compris que c'était lui parce que c'est
un jeune
qui généralement vient avec son père
puis en vrai je vois son père
il est où le fils
et après je l'ai joué
ça c'est marrant parce que j'avais à la
fin j'avais une position j'avais
je crois quatre pièces pour la dame un
truc comme ça mais c'est une position
très très bizarre ça c'est marrant genre
j'avais j'avais dame et 4 pièces contre
deux dames
ça peut barder très très fort pour
pour
aller prendre des cartes qui qui est
jouable là
[Rires]
je mange là
un tour comme ça qui doit être
il a reprises c'est la partie
comment est-ce qu'on finit toujours 8
ok c'est trop il se passe quoi
tout
Arnaud qui voulait voter
je suis désolé on peut pas annuler Pas
de souci
mais ça annule tout ouais mais après les
gens vont revouter et je peux pas
l'annuler moi parce que j'ai voté non
arrête
on pourra pas on pourra pas on pourra
pas
je crois que
je crois que c'est ça ouais des deux
terrible mais comment on finit
je devrais être là mais
j'aime bien ça
à chaque fois
il a pris le 2
il s'entend moi j'ai pensé à ça
un truc comme ça ou cavaler prendre
d'abord je voulais faire une fourchette
un truc mais ça marchera pas
faut prendre
il va bouger la dame peut-être d'en
prendre des cartes
est-ce que j'ai pas un dame là-haut
aussi qui peut être pas mal
quand tu prends là haut prise voilà
qui aime faible
il y a trois pions pour la pièce déjà
plus attaque
est-ce que ça peut se faire tout
je pense que oui ça va fort
même genre ça par exemple
c'est difficile de tout tenir le
cavalier des deux à surveiller le fou
trouver
un peu plus tôt il a laissé venir le fou
un F3 un peu surprenant la partie
[Musique]
tour + 3 pions 5 + 3 fataux
tu sais faire
il a sacrifié il a commencé par
sacrifier son fou mais tout de suite
derrière il gagne et regarde il regarde
du matériel parce que ça posture
beaucoup trop forte
après attention quand même parce que là
des fois il peut y avoir des trucs en
prison alors je suis pas sûr que ce soit
bon mais faire attention pour ces deux
alors parce qu'on met le roi ici
peut-être
sur
essayer mais sur ça il y aura pas trop
vite il va pas l'aider à monter des
trois peut-être sur ça peut-être faire
ça ah il vient ici
mais c'est bizarre tu vois je vais venir
là
le malin Nakamura sur sa il va manger là
attention si j'arrive à défendre mes
pièces sur à manger lui il va faire un
cavalier là ça peut le faire
parce que j'ai quand même deux pièces
pour la tour j'arrive à je commence à
ramasser les pions
ces trois c'est pas forcément le bon
coup
tu vois ce qu'on gagne la photo
OK
blanc là contre 2 minutes pour les Noirs
c'est du chaos et à partir du 40e coup
donc là on est 32e mais au 40e coup et
ben les joueurs se verront ajouter
un incrément de seulement une seconde
pas grand chose
il veut avoir cette up là et ils gardent
depuis un H2 peut-être essayer de se
mettre une tour quelque part en
essayer de c'est dur peut-être
essayer de jouer un setup comme ça avec
cavalue E3 attendez
[Musique]
attention tous vos quatre
il a été fin parce que je peux je vois
ici il y aura toujours
ça peut
laisser des trucs
qui est qui joue vite
ma meilleure offre qui a pas réussi à
concrétiser
sur la prise à tout reprend échecs 4
et si je fais ça peut-être
c'est la partie
40e
maintenant il y a un incrément d'une
seconde à chaque fois
ne le suffit pour les Noirs oui mais bon
si je commence à
activer mes pièces
pour la tour alors et depuis un moment
et c'est pour ça qu'on avait peur à
l'entrée de la finale avec trois pions
une tour 3 pions pour les deux pièces
mais si manœuvre bien et là il arrive il
arrive à tout défendre à tout bloquer
et avancer petit à petit donc si on
continue comme ça pourquoi pas je veux
dire qu'il y a quelques coups il était
foutu et là il a envie
donc il y a très peu de temps chez les
Noirs
Nakamura c'est une fouine
et
bon bah écoutez il a envie en tout cas
il a envie mais c'est vrai que les noirs
sont encore mieux hein
normalement ça fait bien passer quand
même pour
peut faire la différence
j'ai pas vu que c'était toi
il a parlé depuis longtemps
sont revenus pas mal
elle le roi s'active
le relance active après ça reste
difficile en pratique pour les deux
joueurs c'est un Bullet là deux minutes
pour les blancs contre une minute pour
les noirs
sont plus fortes
ou pas mais là j'ai pas pu passer en
tout cas avec les noirs pour ça que
l'avantage n'était pas il se voit pas
encore et le fou de sang qui a été joué
par Nakamura c'est pas mal ça permet de
empêcher les échanges de pièces
contrôler un peu la position
avec trois C4
il est un peu comme ça
c'est quand même pas mal aussi
avoir des idées
tous vos quatre mal joué pas un rêve de
majeur que de toi ça a permis l'échange
des pièces
pour le noir et maintenant maintenant la
potion noir à l'écrasante je pense parce
que maintenant il y a plus de tour chez
les Blancs l'activité est réduite et les
pions je tape contre deux ici et tout je
crois que
il va rendre les armes très bientôt
avec ça je ne sais pas
ah si ça a été joué pourquoi pas ça
empêche cavalier
tours
par là
je prends là tu prends là bon chacun
n'est pas passé on sait pas comment on
peut
c'est ce qui fait
sur
de gigoter quoi avec ton cavalier
il a mis le fous devant OK
10 secondes pour les noirs
qui joue contre Nakamura il a un gros
avantage mais il a une finale avec
avec seulement 10 secondes plus une
seconde parcours
c'est hyper chaud Fatou
E3
il a défendu comme ça il est un peu
obligé de mettre comme ça
il est un peu obligé pour garder les
pièces et il pousse et il pousse
à avoir à de belles chances de gain
quand même ici
[Musique]
qui est gagnante maintenant
et apparemment il est tombé vous voyez
les joueurs je sais pas si vous avez vu
je sais pas si vous avez vu qu'il y a
trouvé tour à deux qui faisait nul mais
il est tombé en entendant il est tombé
et toi c'est hyper bien joué c'est hyper
joli ça empêche la dame sur cavalier
n'arrive plus à temps pour empêcher la
dame et sur A8 dame il y a eu un dame et
là c'est nul mais il est tombé en
chanson
c'est quand même une belle finale pas
tout
mais c'est ouf vu la partie qui nous ont
fait c'est un peu ouf mais c'est un peu
dans le dans le style Naka
donc on a une partie qui est terminée
alors
je vous propose tout ce qu'on retourne
voir la partie de Magnus contre Ali
raisin et il s'est passé un tas de
choses
on s'est arrêté à fou je sais non il
faut prendre et puis en fait
c'est ça donc
ok je suis déçu
tu peux dire tu peux dire il y en a
plein
mais ok je suis un peu déçu
donc Détroit il y a eu G4 et on en
parlait de 4 ans qui allait un jour
arriver et il est venu en D2 pour pour
se replacer peut-être même via B3 pour
attaquer c'est 5 un jour vu que
maintenant a changé de la grenade ou
même des fois venir en C4 3 et les Noirs
H5 qui bien sûr défend J4 c'est aussi un
couple qui est assez compromettant H5
parce que Ben toute la roi des noirs est
ouverte donc maintenant écoute si je
fais comme F3 je commence à regarder
comme échec
et ça va me faire peur je vais là
ça peut des fois se faire un peu peur
même si je pense qu'il y a pas grand
chose
mais je pense qu'avant de faire F3 il va
prendre son temps il va sortir de la
pièce moi je verrai bien un coup comme
cavalier C4
pour voir un peu vraiment comment ça se
passe même cavalier B3 alors pas mal
attaque le pion en ce qui joue ça tu
joues ça et tu joues F3 moi j'aurais
rien faire ça ça et ça et ça a l'air pas
mal du tout
mais ils ont posé tous les pions c'est
assez marrant comme production c'est
très créatif
très créatif j'aimerais bien que que
notre ami Ali résa vienne nous faire
confession sur le chat mais je pense
qu'on peut mais
je pense pas il est pas comme ça c'est
la partie cavalier métro je pars Magnus
et ben écoute moi je préfère toujours
grandement les blancs
mais
à regarder j'aime ce que font les noirs
et ce truc là ça m'aurait trop trop plu
quand j'étais jeune maintenant
ça me fait peur
ça me fait peur pour les noirs
je sais pas si c'est que j'ai progressé
aussi que aussi c'est que j'ai je sais
plus mature qu'avant
mais sûrement
qu'on peut pas être content d'avoir
donc bon
je suis pareil je pense iranien iranien
norvégien je pense que je suis au même
niveau et mon niveau il est pas très
très haut sache-le je pense que si les
réserves venaient faire une confession
qui vient changer le pays je le ferai
surtout pas en iranien je pense ça
serait bizarre trois fois
ce serait étrange
allez si on fait un petit tour là pour
aller voir un peu ce qui se passe au et
à présent donc moi j'avais parlé sur 1-0
depuis le début
voir ce qui s'est passé rapidement
un candidat acceptée
apparemment c'est un coup qui donne pour
un d'interrogation Fatou j'espère que tu
es content d'avoir pris ce pari là
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui peut se passer ici
pourquoi est-ce que c'est pas bon donc
je sais pas ce qu'il veut faire avec les
G4 des fois
que je veux prendre et j'aurais pu au
pire des KF4 je te chasse et je prends
l'espace tu vois je suis pas sûr qu'il y
avait les 5 sont vraiment l'idée d'un
match simple
bon
Cavalaire a priori il est là quoi
comment on punit tout
d'abord on mange un pion
on peut
manger un pion
c'est peut-être pas si c'est simple mais
c'est compliqué et bon apparemment c'est
pas le coup de la jauge
qu'est-ce qui se passe ici
Fatou j'ai besoin de ton aide il faut
que tu m'explique
je vois pas trop
mais l'ordinateur il est jamais d'accord
avec moi votre
[Musique]
comme ça
je sais pas je sais pas ce qu'on fait
pas tout
ce qui est
après des fois là je descend alors que
j'avais raison
chevalier c'est 4 puis 5
ouais mais ça et ça ouais mais je vois
pas en quoi tu m'aides enfin tu fais un
truc ici
Alicia parce que Cavalaire déjà je peux
faire des choses
mais en plus je sens que c'est pas un
très bon coup je pense parce que tu mets
l'ampoule sur quasiment
je m'en fous va être actif tout d'un
coup une fois que ton plan sera parti
alors là mon fou il a pas trop de casse
tu vois pas de bon je peux l'enlever
5 pression quand même c'est pas mal
passé pour moi
[Musique]
je vais mettre la jauge enfin les
parties le truc Fatou va tricher le truc
et le truc et j'avais à moitié raison
parce que je trouvais le premier coup
et deuxième couche de pas trouvé j'ai
pensé à la dame à 4
tu hésites entre ça et ça falloir entre
ça et ça
et apparemment
et si on compte les pièces on a récupéré
juste le pion qu'on avait en retard mais
cette structure qui est absolument
dégueulasse
ça a pas l'air terrible pour le noir ça
fait tout
nulle part
il est pas en forme
on l'a bien vu donc c'est vrai que là
encore faire une mauvaise partie ça peut
arriver encore il est dans le rythme
alors si on va voir un petit peu carwana
Goku
donc moi j'ai parlé j'ai parié sur un
1-0 de sa vie je pensais que Fabi
pouvait mettre la pression à Google
sur la nul je pense que tu es pas mal
souvent au début cette ouverture un peu
bizarre je crois
le début
c'est position on les voit souvent sa
position donc
roi H1 A3 B4 le four en B2 peut-être on
va dire
un petit peu
et H3 tours
ok ben écoute on risque d'avoir ça
peut-être
maybe
il y a un pion de plus pour les blancs
c'est extrêmement solide chez les noirs
c'est pas ce qu'on pourrait essayer de
tenter ici
mais
[Musique]
la potion noir alors quand même très
solitaire le fou il est fort le
cavaliers ont du masque à se
marre
ça ça joue pas quoi
je t'en bouge un tu as un problème
toutes les pièces en fait juste les
pièces sont bonnes mais il y a une
coordination qui enfin je peux pas
mais le fait que les pièces sont mal
coordonnées Fatou effectivement
ça va peut-être un petit pion retard qui
s'appelle
donc
à un moment donné moi je vais je vais
raser là tu vas manger là entre temps et
ça risque de broyer un petit peu plus
sec les blancs parce qu'il y a un point
de plus quand même mais je suis pas sûr
que ça aille vraiment très loin cette
histoire
en tout cas
donc OK et notre ami contre
Paris
alors depuis le début
D5 qui est catalan avec G3
dans ma 4e conseil 4 tout ça c'est hyper
pratique
les 5 c'est 4
ou G5
ok donc
que se passe-t-il ici pas tout je crois
que sur carré de prendre des cinq je
crois qu'il y avait des bécasses
surprises
je sais pas si c'est vraiment grave pour
que j'ai dans ma carte
ou Dame des deux
cas ça offre un pion mais après j'ai
aussi la colonne ouverte qui peut
recevoir sur le tomber dehors donc
c'était pas si grave
quand on voit le temps
c'est vrai j'ai pas vu Alicia mais 48
minutes contre 1h51 c'est enfin
guéri on dirait il a encore
dans un préparation quoi
il a dépensé 9 minutes
alors que tu arrives il a dépensé
quasiment 45 minutes
ah oui là on peut prédire un bon déjà de
Tariq qui chante assez difficile
on regarde Magnus et
il a eu F4
et j'ai pensé aussi tout à l'heure parce
que il y a deux écoles
soit toujours
F3 pour essayer de
jouer sur la colonne FP sur F7 soit
directement avec F4 en fait tu le
laisses il veut prendre en passant et si
votre part en passant tu seras F5 et tu
vas ouvrir
donc ces deux écoles et là ma vie ça
joue F4 donc là on peut imaginer que
j'arrive pas à enlever cette case là
et sur F4 il y a quelqu'un
je pense que l'intention de Magnus sont
plein
il veut tout envoyer
ici
quel plan des blancs en fait
je pensais à Dieu
peut-être pas forcément tout de suite je
pense que le 5 ça arrive d'être un coup
qui va être genre ça
puis ça
et un jour essayer de faire le 5 pour
casser un peu le CASE noir tu vois
essayer de tout casser ouvrir la
position
ça a l'air pas mal
mais sinon elle c'est possible
ça peut donner l'impression
je suis pas sûr que ça soit vraiment si
bien que ça ici
et les Noirs
mais est-ce que un jour je peux essayer
de jouer f515 blanche sachant que
les Blancs n'ont pas fait 15 ans
c'est bizarre mais j'ai envie d'essayer
de
fermer un peu la position quoi et
j'ai envie de t'empêcher un petit peu la
poussière après c'est
la potion non je suis quand même pas mal
j'aime bien les blancs ici
et ça ce serait mon plan je pense mon
plan de jeu avec les Blancs j'essaierai
de faire un truc du style là
pour vraiment ouvrir la position
au maximum sur le roi noir qui qui est
pas développé et qui a pas d'abri pour
son roi
ça me paraît assez
logique
est-ce que tu as une idée de tout un
autre plan qu'on pourrait faire un truc
qu'on pourrait avoir ici
pas vraiment
cette partie me laisse perplexe
spécial donc
donc il y a pas un plan très simple qui
qui vient à l'esprit
pour les blancs
avec les noirs
c'est la question
ça jouer ça et sur ça je vais ça
je reviens
des fois je peux donner un pion comme ça
avec
F4 des fois
et je tourne c'est assez bizarre je sais
pas Magnus alors fou des deux ça donne
une qualité on l'a dit il est là pour
s'amuser
qui a été raté par Magnus
c'est une blague l'idée ici c'est que
sur faut prendre des deux il veut jouer
et s'emparer du foot 15 mars noirs et
développement sont beaucoup plus
importants
que le
seul pièce développée
et d'ailleurs il y a une partie qui a
été jouée au tata style cette année
entre Carlson avec les Blancs contre
aptov
et écarter n'avait sacrifice à tour
pareil un peu de même genre contrat
hyper fort en pratique
et je te dire que ça s'est mal passé
Abdou a très bien réagi il a mangé la
tour il a défendu il a gagné
donc là aussi il faut pas non plus être
derrière on doit être
là on doit finir le travail on peut pas
sacrifier et rien faire derrière
ouais après c'est ça reste compliqué
parce qu'il y a quand même du
du matériel de moins la sincérité c'est
les cases noires en contrepartie et
[Musique]
c'est chaud
est-ce que moi je pense que à ça c'est
un genre très concret calcule
extrêmement bien et si il pense qu'il
peut manger B2 et ben il va le manger
elle a peur que personne donc
c'est un bonbon défenseur oui mais
mais
là c'est une position où tu calcules en
fait
donc genre ça et puis après je sais pas
peut-être
et après je sais pas comment on joue
c'est compliqué mais toi tu ressens pour
cavalier
tout le temps
et en plus quand j'ai souvent une dame
des cadrer chaque qui peut arriver donc
là on disait que tu peux rester présent
à la fin pour valider la prédiction
parce que tous les mots
avant que le stream s'arrête c'est ça
parce que Fatou a
osé par rire la prédiction qu'elle a
elle-même lancée et donc on est bloqué
tu es obligé
est-ce que tu as vu le début de partie
est-ce que tu as vu l'ouverture
salut à tous je sais pas j'ai
l'impression que c'est pour jouer les
cases noires sur du long terme c'est pas
un gain rapide
mais oui bien sûr c'est ça
c'est pas là maintenant tactique ce soit
long terme mais stephyrule considère que
ça tient il va la manger la qualité ça
je peux le dire
puisque c'est une partie des gens qui
sont quand même assez assez concrets
il faut prendre des deux cavaler C3
1 ça a l'air extrêmement chaud
je pense que ça c'est pas bon ça c'est
pas bon
parce qu'il nous reste là
d'ailleurs on a eu après une confession
de Magnus Robinson on a une confession
de Magnus qui disait que
il a quand il s'est préparé il a il a
anticipé à peu près tout ce que pouvait
jouer
fil rouge un
et quand un furosa il a vu la sirène E6
il a dit ah ben ça j'ai pas préparé donc
il a voulu sortir de la préparation en
jouant un fou Detroit voilà et surtout
des trois et ben ça a contre
nous préparations avec G5 et il est venu
au confessionnal à ce moment-là en
disant que c'était marrant en tout cas
c'est une partie qu'elle est fun et que
être hors prépa au bout de trois coups
tous les deux c'était assez marrant et
du coup il faut s'amusant
le fait que c'est une partie
comme ça
donc donc j'ai 6 je sais pas comment on
continue ici Fatou
un petit peu hein
[Musique]
moi j'ai pas regardé
là je suis quand même les pieds
un peu mieux parce que là maintenant
j'ai plus de cavalier qui me bloque je
peux jouer déjà dans 9 6 quoi ou dame G7
ok merci Robinson
mais ça on l'avait pas
[Musique]
de oui en fait Robin side c'est un
schéma que tu vois dans plein d'autres
positions sauf les trois pour après
jouer
quand on ouvre le 3 ici pour après je
sais trois fois c'est deux et des 4 tu
le vois dans dans plein plein de
variantes de la Sicilienne en fait car
c'est une sédiment ça je fais ça et puis
je remets pièces on verra bien
et donc voilà quoi
créativité est tellement rare à ce
niveau qu'on va pas dire non ah oui non
mais c'est clair je pense qu'on est
hyper content de voir cette partie en
tout cas moi je suis par contre
je pense que ma musique est content de
une partie ou vraiment les deux vont
s'envoyer dans la gueule alors que
souvent
ce qui est très content d'aller raisins
en général et de ce qui peut proposer
dans le jeu
les joueurs de manière générale contre
Magnus et ben il joue serré ils veulent
pas prendre de risques ils veulent
essayer de faire nul la majorité et en
fait l'animal génération elle s'en fout
un blanc noir elle veut essayer de
gagner parce qu'elle prend l'expérience
et puis je Magnus quoi et firou
il s'en fout juste il veut juste gagner
quoi donc peu importe dans qui joue il
respecte rien et il a bien raison
d'ailleurs et donc et donc après il est
bien content aussi de construire ce type
de joueur parce que
il mange B2 tu vois c'était clair
qu'elle allait manger B2
et
la partie commence là
la partie commence Fatou
pratique
il va donner son meilleur ici j'en suis
convaincu la victoire de Firo sur un
chef-d'oeuvre oui il dit qu'il faut pas
manger la tour là dessus
5 il faut que tu bouges en tout cas
pas envisager F5 après G6
puis D4 pour ouvrir un roi
[Musique]
peut-être
mais par exemple ça ça
peut être ça et si tu bouges de cavalier
mais là j'ai quand même aussi cavalier 5
qui peut qui peut arriver et qu'elle
peut peut-être tout bloquer aussi donc
attention les cornes je suis pas sûr que
le cabanon 5 soit
bien pour les pour les blancs peut-être
que ici essaie de garder un peu cette
chaîne de pion pour empêcher de cavaler
de bouger à la place faire la F6 m'a
l'air pas mal ou dame j'ai 7
et maintenant mena César peut-être
et même sur un truc comme ça je vais me
dire
ça peut très très vite tourner hein
ciao
et 5 cette idée qu'on avait tout à
l'heure d'essayer de d'ouvrir un petit
peu les cases noires et tout
moi j'aime bien les blancs ces
production ça fait depuis le début de la
partie que je te le dis je trouve que ce
que fait l'iranha c'est beaucoup trop
borderline et contre Carlson après c'est
à Paris
pollution qui sont très très chaudes
mais bon j'ai du mal à y croire
ma décroissant les mecs
et oui il y a pas de prépa ici
c'est l'humain qui joue et il s'amuse
tous les deux
c'est pour ça que c'est beau à voir
on n'a pas les récitations habituelles
des ouvertures on sort un petit peu du
classique
c'est pour ça que ça nous fait plaisir
et j'espère que tout le chat on est ravi
mais après c'est aussi plus difficile
parce que du coup il faut il faut
chercher dans des schémas qu'on connaît
pas
donc pour nous bien sûr spectateur mais
pour les joueurs aussi
même si les joueurs ils connaissent un
petit peu tout ils sont quand même très
très fort
mais en tout cas ils doivent ils doivent
innover
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on fait un petit tour ailleurs
avant de revenir ici on va regarder
oui on peut aller faire un petit tour
alors donc Magnus firou c'est c'est
extrêmement compliqué et écoute ça m'a
l'air très intéressant moi je pense
qu'il va pas manger je pense qu'il va
rester que ça s'enfonge et 7 il est dit
bon je vais manger un pion et je et je
pars
alors si on fait saut Abdou ici
alors on avait dit que le coup carré G4
était pas terrible c'était la jauge qui
nous avait dit que j'ai 4 c'était
vraiment pas bon il a mangé il a joué la
meilleure ligne
[Musique]
saut et maintenant que se passe-t-il
après tu reprends ceci
ça peut être drôle regarde j'ai trouvé
l'idée ça marche
si je vais
c'est drôle
sauf que là
[Musique]
sortir je pense quand même
mais qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire en fait
ici
[Musique]
l'attaque de maths j'ai l'impression
qu'elle n'a rien du tout non
je sais pas si
j'ai du mal à croire je comprends pas
tout aide-moi comprendre
même si tu arrives à faire prise je
prends tout reprendre bon ça marchera
pas mais tu en prends là j'ai encore
l'autre cavalier qui vient donc
j'ai beaucoup de mal à comprendre pas
tout je peux mettre la jauge
je viens de voir une tactique et j'ai
mis 30 secondes à comprendre les coups
waouh intéressant parce que est-ce que
tu vois mon écran bateau est-ce que toi
le coup des Noirs ici les Noirs jouent
et
les Noirs jouent et presque gagné
c'est un truc de fou
j'ai pas pensé alors là
jolie
c'est joli
pour ceux qui veulent proposer des
solutions
c'est joli
OK
je crois que tu la rappelles vas-y
n'hésite pas
on fait l'exercice sur le chat
[Musique]
et là c'est un peu bête
là je sais pas trop ce que je menace
parce que dans mes chèques j'ai toujours
un point F2 mais bon j'ai mangé un peu
important qu'un vampire je reviens et ça
va
mais là c'est du fait tour reprend F2
maintenant j'ai tortue parce que la tour
défend plus ici
je peux pas bouger et défendre la tour
jolie
c'est un peu un coup invisible quoi tu
penses pas quoi
et si je fais vous aussi
je suis encore du mal à comprendre enfin
tout
OK
qui tape sur le cahier des deux
ouais mais bon
c'est curieux cette position
c'est vraiment curieux parce que mettre
une dame en H6 comme ça c'est un truc
que j'aurais jamais fait tu alors et là
je m'en fous waouh
alors ça va contre mon coup n'avait pas
l'air terrible
mais sur ça
je voyais pas la suite
miauler
c'est à chaque fois quand elle se
réveille de la sieste
et ben je vois que ça peluche et elle
pleure d'émotion
c'est tout
elle va venir dans quelques secondes
elle va se par exemple moi et elle va se
recoucher parce que après la sieste
fou des selles il faut manger la dame si
je mange pas la dame je pars une qualité
donc il va falloir manger la dame et
surtout reprendre H6 et foutrant à 4 il
va falloir trouver une case pour la tour
parce qu'on a dit que là c'est
impossible et que si je vais ici sur
cette case là en verte et ben on se rend
fou B5 attaque les deux tours
simultanément
donc
on peut imaginer à ce tour là
il manquait et ma tour elle ressort je
crois a priori
[Musique]
et je peux aussi aller en H4 il mange à
6 il faut prendre un 4 écoute je pense
qu'on va voir
on va voir un petit zéro
Fatou j'avais encore une fois
bien parier
je suis assez fier de moi
alors
3 4 1 3 4 donc bah écoute les pièces
s'échangent j'ai un pion qui est passé
ici
mais je pense pas que ça fasse
grand-chose
est-ce qu'il y a eu une répétition ou
pas
C4 qui avait le 5 non
pour aller voir rapidement Alicia ouais
on va y aller
un truc comme ça
et juste maintenant ça bouge plus
ça bouge plus un truc comme ça nul
j'accepte
mais bon c'est une partie qui va faire
nul je pense il y a pas trop de suspense
et donc c'est pas mal qui fait nul assez
facilement avec le noir contre carbone
quand même
donc écoute c'est un bon résultat je
pense pour le genre indien
et
guérir alors moi j'avais lancé une
petite nulle et toi tu avais
annoncé
Kiri qui gagne la partie classique moi
j'avais annoncé Tariq gagnant
en armée
alors attends on s'est arrêté je sais
plus trop où par là ouais il a mangé des
cinq on a on s'est arrêté à ça
et qu'avec le sein qui a eu qui avait
les B4 et sur Dame des deux
par la jauge
alors apparemment le coup c'était plutôt
tour B8 ici sur le temps prend C4 peut y
avoir des trucs comme ça
si je mange pas sur le plan B
je mange là
j'arrive à être très actif là j'ai un
plan de moi mais
je suis assez actif là
pourquoi
est-ce que
chaque prise menace bon il y a pas
d'échec
et puis on prend logiquement cavalier F3
et calculer ce qu'on peut prendre le fou
un F6
faut réfléchir en tout cas
si je peux manger F6 c'est cool mais
après ça
moi je vois ça
moi je pense que je celle là j'ai un bon
fou quand même ici
contre le purin
[Musique]
c'est pas encore gagnant mais
c'est pas bon et pourquoi pas
[Musique]
on est obligé
en plus mais
qu'est-ce qu'on peut jouer à la place de
tout ça parce qu'on a eu pour l'instant
ça nous a pas trop trop
je pense que c'était quand même
on prend un fou prend je mets bien
tourner
je trouvais ça pas mal pour les blancs
maintenant à ce que j'ai mieux que ça
encore
je perds le pion non
tout est changé et placer le tour en 7
ouais mais bon trois comptes 4 je suis
pas sûr que ça fasse quelque chose
vraiment Licorne
à la fin
j'y crois pas du tout
ton rêve bien
c'est un peu mieux déjà mais
je viens vite prendre et puis après un
tour bien tu veux manger quoi
moi je vais prendre 5
qu'est-ce que tu fais
laissez faire j'aime pas
me laisser manger
ce qu'il faut avoir dessus l'attaque
ce pion va être perdu donc faut être
dynamique
un truc comme ça
ça peut mal se passer
[Musique]
il a du temps pour réfléchir à tout ça
et puis on prend l'air quand même le
coup numéro 1 pardon
par élimination
je vois bien un truc comme ça arrivé
alors toi
et là derrière si je bouge je m'en fous
mais en fait je pense que toi c'est
votre opposé on va changer les tours on
va au fur et à mesure ça risque de faire
mieux je pense franchement
j'ai essayé trois G7 tous en case noir
et tu vas essayer de vite mettre tes
tortures à la colonne enfin deuxième
rangée
il y a de belles chances quand même de
faire de nul après ça que les blancs on
la pression ils peuvent mettre attention
quel point faible
mais ce que j'arrive à gagner
pas que là mais ça m'a l'air d'être un
coup quand même peut-être le coup numéro
1 des français
[Musique]
alors que nous on peut attaquer FC avec
les Blancs
comme ça nous on pourrait se faire ça
tout mettre
c'est plus ça que que le fait juste
d'avoir un pion d'avance mais qui soit
placé
on va dire assez bien
qui va défendre F2 qui va empêcher des
attaques sur le plan F2
mais puis il y a aussi un peu en plus
hein quand même hein
il faut
il faut le faire parler il est pas passé
ce pion de plus
40 minutes d'avance
c'est incroyable
c'est beaucoup
et s'il arrive à les conserver encore un
petit peu
ça va faire du bien dans la fin
encore petit
n'a pas pris la tour
aller
en G7 il a considéré que les classes
noires étaient trop faible si manger la
tour
et donc il est rentré à la maison il
vient de manger un petit pion et il
vient de maintenant le coup dame qui a
un coup apparemment brillant de
l'ordinateur qui permet à la dame de
venir sur les cases noires par ici et
encore une fois il laisse la tour il
laisse les raisins revenir à manger ici
mais s'il a pas mangé coûte avant et ben
il va pas le manger maintenant parce
qu'en plus c'est la potion qui
retransposerait en fait parce qu'il y a
pas eu de coups
supplémentaire jouer
donc et là c'est chaud parce que
toujours cavalier je sais par exemple en
fait j'ai cinq exercices
qui peut paraître chaud puis j'ai
toujours l'idée de faire carrer ces
quatre pour taper sur les cases noires
tu vois l'idée de faire
et puis on prend et manger et par ici
bon il y a Dame des cartes qu'il faut
regarder il faut s'envoyer ça mais c'est
chaud franchement
je commence à vraiment vraiment beaucoup
aimé la potion de Magnus alors depuis le
début je l'aime
avec un petit fou assis
ok mais même si toujours aussi imaginons
tu prends
et
toujours après
le 4 tu auras du mal à l'avancer et je
pense que j'aurais l'impression que ce
soit plus en désiste tout le temps par
exemple même ça
mais du coup ça te ça ralentit dans ton
idée de 5 pas forcément en fait moi je
m'en fous moi j'ai le temps lui il fait
quoi en fait
ça ça a pas l'air très ça a pas l'air
génial
mais bon ok ben écoute je
continue de penser que que Magnus a un
énorme avantage la jauge elle est pas si
critique que moi
mais je trouve qu'en pratique c'est trop
dur en fait la jauge elle est pas
humaine
c'est l'ordinateur qui calcule
absolument tout et considère qu'en
calculant tout ça va les planches un peu
mieux mais sans plus
et il y a quand même un pion de moi pour
les blancs donc là on l'avantage malgré
tout le monde ça me prend un petit peu
le contre-jour mais nous en tant
qu'humain même si eux qui calculent très
très bien et ben malgré tout en tant
qu'humain je trouve que c'est
extrêmement difficile de
jouer avec le noir à regarder même
qu'avec ces quatre l'idée de jouer là un
jour le 5 on en a parlé mais j'ai aussi
ces trois qui peut arriver derrière
échanger les fous et après rentrer que
Madame par là un peu la même idée que
j'avais avant mais sur le long terme
j'ai trop de thèmes j'ai toujours eu 5
toujours F5 j'ai toujours plein de
possibilités alors que les Noirs ont peu
de possibilités et je trouve que la
position à la série en l'idée et en
attaque chez les Blancs chez noir c'est
trop difficile j'aime pas du tout la
position dans les raisins
j'aime pas du tout je suis hyper
critique
j'aime pas
je trouve qu'en pratique c'est
extrêmement dur la moindre erreur qui va
commettre l'IRESA bah il va il va te
mettre quoi
alors
même s'il fait un il fait des mauvais
coups
de noir est hyper ouverte
des pions avancés
etc les pièces noires qui ont du mal à
bouger aussi
c'est marrant composition en tout cas
ça c'est marrant ok 1h chacun 14 minutes
la cadence c'est 2h ko avec 10 secondes
de rajoutant à partir de 40e coups donc
là ils ont plus qu'une heure à la
pendule c'est assez chaud
une jauge ordinateur
et une jauge grand maître
et ouais après sur la joue c'est pas mal
aussi mais c'est vrai que la jauge nous
et moi elle nous adore
elle nous aide parce que ça permet de
savoir à peu près ce qui se passe quoi
un peu plus vite quoi
on voit à quel point on peut surveiller
sur les
positions
et je vois même peuvent envoyer parce
que
parce que eux non plus ils ont pas la
jauge hein quand ils vont pas je sais
pas si ils arrivent à évaluer
précisément alors
alors position
si j'imagine je sais pas s'il y a les
raisins il s'imagine
que que ça va c'est ok
pense hein par rapport à ce qu'il a joué
il aurait pas joué ça si tu sais c'est
totalement totalement en naze
donc il doit bien croire en ce qui joue
après c'est quand même un joueur qui est
je pense qu'il est capable tu sais la
glissage de fouiller les trois et la
queue c'est un peu trop là et vu le
programme qui fait il fait un moyen il
faut que Magnus c'est la partie qui
espérait il veut faire ce spectacle je
pense qu'il y a un peu de tout et il y a
aussi l'aspect surprise tout ça bien sûr
mais ok il a un style à jeu très créatif
je pense qu'il y a un peu de peut-être
mais bon ça reste ce qu'on a vu mais je
sais pas
ils ont pas la jauge mais ils sont très
très forts quand même donc ils
comprennent mieux que nous
en fait eux ils ont pas d'argent ils
comprennent beaucoup mieux et qui
calcule beaucoup mieux mais
nous avec un jour
bah ouais sinon
après même si depuis le début je te dis
tiens-moi je suis hyper critique je dis
qu'il est long ont un gros avantage
alors qu'un jour je dis que c'est égal
tu vois et je reste fidèle à ce que je
pense même si elle a jauge je m'en fous
je trouve que
humainement c'est beaucoup plus facile à
jouer ok avec les Noirs l'aspect
l'aspect pratique est tellement
tellement présent tellement important
que ça devient trop dur pour les Noirs
c'est moi cette position avec les Noirs
c'est un cauchemar
je serai je serais pas bien
avec les Blancs par contre je serai je
serai pas content c'est vraiment
l'impression que j'aime bien tu vois
qu'avec ces quatre C3 on a parlé des
plans
je vous laisse à jouer ça je
éventuellement ça ou ça c'est en fait
les blancs le jeu des blancs est hyper
facile à jouer parce que les thèmes sont
là et les coûts c'est facile on va vers
l'avant chez les Noirs je trouve qu'il
faut jouer hyper précis je vais faire un
truc Fatou je vais mettre l'ordinateur
juste pour voir
pour voir combien il y a de couloirs qui
permettent de garder l'égalité d'accord
je mets
le test malheureusement
[Musique]
analyse je vais en mettre ah je suis
trop max
et salut GB
on s'en fout
ça on s'en fout ok ok
bon apparemment F5 donne 0,33 pour les
blancs il faut assise donne 0,44 pour
les blancs
et j'aimerais savoir si le troisième
coup blanc est-ce que le troisième coup
noir
et jouable ou pas parce qu'en fait
je pense que pour garder l'égalité avec
les Noirs il faut que les Noirs jouent
une série de de coups quasi forcé
tu vois et c'est hyper dur alors que les
Blancs c'est facile
on a compris que sur airstone qui va
jouer 5 c'est clair si on voulait plus
tard
et on a compris que parfois
un peu tu regardes le 5 voilà dans les
thèmes que on disait ou tourner pour
jeter ces quatre
enfin c'est hyper facile en fait le
thème
[Musique]
le jeu blanc est trop simple
alors que je noir il est très très
précis et je pense que ça va être dur
pour aller raisin cave G3 F5 oui moi je
préfère ça et ça ça va plus vite
tu prends je prends je prends il y a ça
en l'air il y a un chèque ici et la F2
c'est noir après bien sûr le noir arrive
en faire des choses il lui faut assise
s'il y a du F5 et le kf6 il y a des
coiffeurs faut prendre un oui oui c'est
très dur faut prendre un point attaque
la tour et qu'elle agisse déjà j'étais 5
et c'est déjà catastrophe
super quoi j'ai dû E5 j'ai du F5 il y a
tout qui se casse la gueule
ici c'est trop dur regardez les pièces
juste je joue ça je peux jouer ça je
peux jouer ça enfin
c'est trop facile bonjour est trop
facile
j'ai répondu aux deux messages
ça fait deux heures qu'on est là on n'a
pas encore fait de pause
et comme ça on revient
mais bon je passe ça m'intéresse genre
la capote game ça vous va
est-ce que vous voulez
après ça va pas être un bon je vais
regarder mais ça va pas être un truc
très long je pense game ça risque d'être
[Musique]
c'est pas possible parce que le four
le fou noir dans le fond blanc
contrôle
la case T8 sur laquelle le roi devrait
passer
non après après grand pourquoi pas après
tout mais bon
tu vois bien que la position quand même
enfin tu vois que tu as des problèmes
dans la production
dangereux alors je vais vous mettre la
le
l'interview de Nakamura d'après
l'Armageddon
et et puis on revient dans 10 minutes ça
va
allez
je vous mets les trucs et on se dit à
tout de suite attendez je mets la bonne
[Musique]
et nous sommes de retour après cette
pause Fatou que s'est-il passé pendant
votre absence
c'est pas encore ce qui s'est passé par
contre qui est là pour nous traduire ce
que a dit
on peut écouter l'autre
plus écoutez ce que nous a dit après son
armage et donc
d'habitude c'est lui qui anime un petit
peu le confessionnal avec tous ces
commentaires de partie
et là il est parti rapidement donc on a
personne sur place pour nous analyser
les parties comme il le faisait
je sais pas est-ce que quelqu'un peut
nous traduire
sinon je peux peut-être de mon côté
aussi
je peux le remettre mais combien de
temps il durait celui-là
il a pas duré trop longtemps on peut le
remettre
dure une minute 37 allez je peux le
mettre si tu veux
United
peux-tu nous traduire ce qui s'est passé
dans le chat
je peux vous aider
ouais alors déjà il a dit enfin
c'est le début mais en gros il dit que
ça partit était foutue il est un peu de
chance il a dit que dans l'armage et
donc quand tu as les blancs il faut
toujours essayer de faire en sorte que
la partie dure le plus longtemps pour
quand on va voir ça soit mal au temps et
essayer de faire un petit blender voilà
et dans la partie évidemment qu'il était
foutu après le sacrifice 3 alors sa
partie et
il est très content d'avoir gagné malgré
tout et après il lui demandait
quels sont tes chances de enfin selon
toi de de bien finir dans le tournoi de
etc il reste encore trois rondes et il a
dit que il a essayé de gagner qu'il
allait essayer de gagner les parties qui
restent etc et que pour l'instant il
entre la deuxième la troisième place
c'est qu'il est assez content et que ça
serait bien pour lui voilà donc après il
a reparlé derrière de sa partie en
disant que oui il a raté F4
et qu'il était foutu mais bon après ça
reste une partie c'est un blitz donc
c'est voilà mais il est content d'être
là elle est content il fait un bon
tournoi et
gagner cette partie qui était foutue et
ben il est aussi content
et puis donc voilà c'est à peu près ça à
peu près tout
et pendant qu'on parlait pas tout il va
on a une partie qui s'est terminée et on
va aller voir rapidement comment la
partie s'est terminée mais c'était
c'était assez prévisible qui avait l'air
assez
assez bien parti pour faire nul on
s'arrête et je crois
qu'une heure de ça
F4 qui avait ici Royal 2
et voilà
19h40
pour l'Armageddon de kerona
donc on ira le voir tout à l'heure
donc il nous reste en partie il nous
reste trois parties pour l'instant le
reste de Magnus car c'est elle contre
les affaires aux gens où il y a eu fou à
6 étourdin donc là on peut imaginer que
les blancs vont préparer car la SC4
ainsi que E5 Fatou c'est le plan qu'on a
énoncé depuis un bon moment maintenant
et je continue de penser que les Blancs
ont un bel avantage cette position
on a du nouveau un petit peu chez So et
abdosotrophe avec la tour d'Abdou
qui a l'air quand même de sortir dehors
de se mettre un pas Cavalaire 6 on a eu
tout à 5 et maintenant ça va être
difficile de ne pas perdre de plan de 4
on a ça en l'air et ça en l'air et des
plans rond un pion on a d'avance on a
l'impression enfin tout va pas trop
comment il va faire Abdou
mais en plus
de 1 je mange un pion de 2 je peux aussi
jouer par exemple Torcéen et aussi voilà
la pression sur en fait les trois pions
noirs ici sont faibles donc la position
est très difficile pour les noirs
et ça c'est clair je pense qu'à ce
niveau là à ce niveau technique là je
pense que
[Musique]
il va gagner tous les jours c'est parti
est tellement énorme que je le vois pas
faire un long résultat que le gars je
pense que ça va gagner alors que chez
Guiri et Ben et ben il y a une tempête
qui a remporté toutes les pièces sur son
passage et il y a eu beaucoup beaucoup
d'échanges donc
on parle de cette partie là vous voyez
la position
on s'est arrêté au coup E5 Fatou le coup
en jaune
et le 5 il y avait puis on prend et il a
mangé
dans C3 sa force de changer d'âme on va
dire
la première chose qu'on avait regardé
alors si tu prends ici je prends là tu
échanges là j'ai un pion de plus mais je
sens de la pluie en deux quatre et je
pense que le pion C4 est plus faible
qu'autre chose donc je pense que le but
dans cette finale là c'est l'échange le
plus possible et je pense bien fait de
manger pour provoquer cet échange là et
pouvoir continuer à mettre la pression
plus tard sur le plan B2
je crois enfin tout que cette finale là
quatre contre trois ici contre 3 et ici
dans chaque 3 contre 3 comme ça c'est
nul 4 contre 3 comme ça ça peut gagner
je pense non
je sais pas du tout
je me demande si on en arrive à échanger
lui par exemple
je la fais un peu grotesque
ça gagne pour les blancs
je sais pas c'est pas clair
par exemple comme ça
peut-être même plutôt devenir ici
d'ailleurs
mais bon je fais tout F4 quand même tu
vas faire ça je fais
peut-être
plus simple pour les blancs
les pions doublés avec une petite cible
pour
infuser pour garder aussi
l'attaque avec le pion B2 pour récupérer
tous mes deux sauf que est-ce que est-ce
que c'est mieux est-ce que c'est mieux
d'avoir échangé bien comme ça d'avoir
réussi
on va voir on va voir si ça fait nul ou
si il est blanc arrive à
en faire quelque chose en tout cas il a
un pion de plus il a aucune chance de
perdre à niche c'est les noirs qui
doivent qui doivent tanquer
c'est clairement les noirs qui jouent
pour essayer d'égaliser mais c'est pas
sur le tout qu'il y arrive c'est pas
clair
donc on a une finale qui peut faire nul
mais qui va encore plus être poussé par
Guy
et on a so Wesley
c'est quelque chose aussi dans la partie
de ce Wesley non je me suis trompé c'est
la partie numéro 2 excusez-moi et dans
ce les et ben il y a eu fou ces deux qui
attaque
le pur 4 il y a eu E5 alors ça me paraît
assez bizarre c'est cool sachant que
maintenant quand le Cavalier rouge il me
semble que j'ai tout C1 tu reprends ce 7
il y aura toujours des trois
[Musique]
j'ai compris
de
troisième désolé mais
sans sans et là peut-être ça
non
j'ai un plan de plus et en plus de ça il
y a encore ça et ça
je pense que ça va être juste perdu pour
pour
se battre il va essayer de trouver des
compensations mais il est très très mal
j'ai quand même beaucoup de mal à
trouver ici des compensations pour
pour les noirs
partie difficile à 4 a été joué
OK
là il y a un carrefour de
possibilités là
de plus mais qui donne du jeu un peu sur
la technologie qui vont rentrer
j'ai aussi
cavalier prend des quatre
à Nancy prends là je prends là mais il
rends à tour ok ça c'est pas possible
donc
j'ai pas tout manger ici en fait
ça c'est pas une possibilité mais j'ai
aussi un
j'ai pas encore mangé la pièce
j'ai un autre conventionnel du carreau
au final 2 en fait apparemment il a eu
d'autres conventions avant mais sans
échiquier
et là maintenant il y a
échiquier il parle un peu de ce qu'il
pense il y a quinzaine qui fait une
grippe confession d'ailleurs parce que
j'ai reçu je sais pas si la conversion
elle est en
train
je pense
mais je vais je vais l'écouter moi-même
si vous voulez
enfin je vais la télécharger déjà ouvrir
un VLC
je vais regarder si c'est dans quelle
langue c'est parce que c'est en
norvégien
mais bon ça veut dire que ça va arriver
bientôt je pense
[Musique]
en anglais peut-être
mais je comprends rien
voilà donc c'est encore en norvégien et
on sait pas ce qu'il va faire
voilà mais j'imagine que bientôt on va
recevoir la confession traduite
en anglais
et ouais j'avoue j'avoue bien mais bon
les gars je sais pas une formation moi
c'est pas une formation je peux pourtant
des langues je peux en parler et
norvégien c'est pas du tout un truc que
j'ai bossé
c'est pas un truc que j'ai bossé et je
pense pas qu'il est de langue qui se
rapproche
du norvégien la langue que je connais ça
quel est le plus simple pour toi Fatou
rester
ouais ok
plus tard je ferai ça et tu mangeras là
je vais manger là-bas
moi
on avait on avait parlé de toutes les
possibilités qu'il y avait un problème
et sur cavaler prend il y a cavalier
prend ou tu reprends donc on va voir ce
que ce préfère jouer
c'est pas gêné par des trois
oui après je peux manœuvrer
mais là
c'est quand même
ça peut-être ça ça
tenir
mais ça ça rentrait ouais non c'est dur
pour les pour les Noirs
plus simple de faire cavaler prendre des
quatre
il a pris ses deux il a pris ses deux
norvégien ça pourrait être utile
on verra
canari
ça parle ça parle espagnol après les pas
toi
je la connais pas
je pense que
je les ai pas appris non plus
j'avais plus rien à dire j'habite à
Valencia je me suis rapproché un petit
peu de vous les gens
et
[Musique]
avance ça parait espagnol mais ça parle
aussi le valencien
et c'est hyper chelou je comprends que
dalle
ça va marcher et la caissière elle me
parle en valant et je lui dis je me dis
espagnol s'il vous plaît quoi
et en fait elle pensait que j'étais à
l'ancien
ces
et j'ai dit oui
je connais très bien c'est dans le sud
moi je suis pas vraiment à Valence amine
je suis pas vraiment avant je suis à ça
gunto c'est à une demi-heure au nord en
fait on a un petit peu long en toi et
moi on est loin toi et moi on est à on
est à 1h30 en fait mais c'est pas très
loin c'est pas très loin
Gandia tu sais que quand j'ai déménagé
j'avais regardé
j'ai trouvé ça intéressant la plage
là-bas
tous les trucs que je trouvais c'était à
chaque fois jusqu'à l'été quoi après il
louait à saisonnière difficile mais j'ai
regardé la possibilité de pouvoir aller
à Gandia
d'ailleurs la semaine dernière j'étais
très proche de toi je crois
il y a plusieurs écritures plus long de
la vie ça dépend comment tu ça dépend si
tu parles en espagnol ou en valencien
c'était à Xavier
sabia donc je pense que ça se dit ça
bien x c'est chaud sinon ça ira bien
Java comme ça c'est sur la côte entre
chez toi et Alicante
voilà je vais attendre là-bas
j'ai fait un tournoi dimanche dernier
que j'ai pas gagné j'ai fait 6 et demi
sur 7
j'ai fait nul à la dernière partie et
j'avais un départage horrible ici alors
que j'ai joué tout le monde
c'est dur la vie
je suis arrivé deuxième avec 6 émissions
deux fois j'avais
deux fois j'arrive au deuxième au
départage mais
c'est quoi pour nous que tu sois pas
premier
personne ne peut imaginer ici que tu
n'arrives pas à provient dans tournoi
j'étais à
[Musique]
là où j'étais allé c'était alors sabia
c'est un truc comme ça je crois que
c'était
après tu as plusieurs écritures
ouais c'est sympa c'est un petit village
un petit village
on va voir un peu
à pain
si Jess tu veux faire un malin bah
écoute c'est un super beau temps de la
situation
je crois que c'en était ça m'arrange pas
trop ça voilà mais c'est pas fin
décembre
c'est pas du tout mais si Jess c'est
Jess c'est c'est proche de Barcelone
c'est Barcelone et je suis quand même
Barcelone si je vais verser là-bas trois
heures de route à chaque fois
trois heures de route
je sais pas si c'est avant ou après
Barcelone et c'est par là-bas
c'est à une demi-heure de Barcelone ou
je sais pas dans quel sens
donc oui c'est quand même
[Musique]
et
je vais voir ce qui s'est passé avant
d'aller voir un magasin
je pense un petit cavalier un petit
cavalier un C4 qui a l'air pas mal enfin
tout c'est que depuis tout à l'heure je
disais ça ça c'est ce qui va arriver et
c'est ce qui arrive à
dans ce cas-là qu'est-ce que tu fais ce
que tu
est-ce que tu as le choix est-ce que tu
veux changer
ça ça
mais bon c'est de toute façon il était
il était perdu depuis le début j'ai
envie de dire
ça en fait
mon petit fou ici et voir ce qui se
passe après par c'est dur c'est dur
franchement j'aime pas la poisse après
l'ordinateur il s'enflamme pas mais moi
j'aime pas
mais je connais pas encore toutes ces
villes
je suis depuis pas longtemps je connais
pas trop là
franchement ça va être sympa
alors est-ce que vous voulez voir
l'Armageddon entre kookesh et Cabana on
va le voir quand même pas étonnant
alors
je crois que c'est un tournoi très fort
il y a plein de gays il y a plein de
super niveau on est plein de grand
maître c'est sympa cuisine
pour ça
il faut que je vois c'est compliqué en
décembre
et oui
je ne sais pas du tout
[Musique]
une sorte de
espagnol d'échange c'est hyper à la mode
franchement là on a 60
toutes les parties c'est ça quoi
kidnapping organisé
docteur stuff
alors Caval et B8
cash alors il veut bien sûr mettre en
cavalier sur une meilleure case hein
la fourchette ou ça a été ça a été
préparé par kervana
et comment sont continue ici Fatou
du mal à
jouer ses positions avec les normes moi
j'aime bien les blancs j'aime bien
attaquer j'aime bien que le camp qui
fait des choses surprise et attaquer
ramener le tour
mais je sais pas moi je suis profil
actif
on se cache
mais ça c'est pas un pion gratuit ça
je regarde les joueurs est-ce qu'il y a
pas un oubli
prise avec les jouets
à manger ses quatre tempo
et là la tactique c'est que quand tu
prends là
je perds le cavalier 4
par contre
et pression sur le pion ici et après je
te fais bon fou quand on est fou enfin
tout
ouais on est pas content
tous les pions tout le monde sur le pion
le 5
e F5
ça a l'air pas génial pour
pour 6 je pense qu'on peut manger en
fait
et on a une meilleure pièce que
l'adversaire Fatou
tu vois quand on sait qu'on a la
meilleure parce que l'adversaire on
échange les bonnes contre les bonnes
regardez là si je fais des couleurs une
bonne chose
entre elles pour vraiment accentuer
l'avantage et jouer avec une bonne
contre une mauvaise qui bien sûr le
fouet 6 qui est une pièce qui allume une
couleur que tous les pions qui a du mal
à bouger donc là je peux manger la tour
du Fou de ce enfin ce que vous voulez
dans tous les cas ça frustration
déjà sur l'autre avoir des deux trop là
est déjà pas mal après on va essayer
plus tard de voir ce qui se passe il y
aura peut-être sacrifice etc
ok après ça peut être aussi possible si
jamais il arrive avant la fête de maths
mais sinon c'est dommage
[Musique]
si ça a été mauvais
moi je l'aurais mis je l'aurais mis en
vert c'est fou je t'aurais dit tiens
petite post-it en rouge sur F6 attends
je vais venir faire tous si on joue
ensemble à avoine je viens avec une
post-it
rouge ça marche
ça serait magnifique j'appellerai
l'arbitre tu es comme ça TOI
et je dis peut-être qu'il y a un truc tu
sais il y a des trucs
on a vu la jauge qui est très très vite
descendu tout en bas et ouais
c'est Google je te présente
4 un peu comme cars
donc trois minutes 48 contre 5,27 c'est
du chaos jusqu'au 40e coup il y aura du
chaos avec une seconde parcours au 40e
les tours
à la fin G6 peut-être ça peut être une
idée pour bien
[Musique]
c'est suffisant pour l'emporter
je regarde ce qui se passe à côté
Magnus il a fait tout ce qu'on a dit en
forme
il joue comme nous
il est aussi bon que nous
toi je pense après je pense que tu es
même un petit peu meilleur mais il est
aussi bon que moi avec la jauge
heureusement que tu as la joie c'est
marrant de jouer avec la jauge
donc là
ça peut être marrant
je pense que ça m'aide vachement la joie
je pense à mettre beaucoup
tu sais qu'il y a quelque chose
mais même des fois tu sais quand tu es
foutu genre pas en plein la position de
Magnus si je suis alliéza excuse-moi
j'ai pas envie de la jouer mais je vois
la jauge je dis bon allez on se bat
excuse-moi on est reparti sur la partie
avec Mala qui veut partir à Sitges
il
s'est dit je veux faire ce tournoi
et toi tu as pas vu ça c'est pour ça
parce que ça marche
ça marche non
ce qui bouge pas ah si un peu quand même
je me dis ça ça
prend là je prends la
je prends là mais avant c'est pas trop
la vidéo
dommage ça avait l'air joli quand le 7
Virgil qui a valu le 3 car wanna
une fois dans la partie où tu peux
demander la jauge à un moment
ce serait pas mal aussi
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
alors il y a presque une tactique
on va ce qui me fait peur dans cette
nana c'est que j'ai l'impression que
tout est sur son faible
donc je vais pas forcément envie de
faire d'apprendre les 7 mais ce pion
soit de long terme il va te faire mais
ok
et voilà et après
après il y a ça en plus
pas déconner chez kerwana
est-ce que tu joues en club
je pense que
tu la demande quand tu sais
qu'il y a une tactique peut-être quand
tu sais pas du tout quoi jouer ça n'a
pas trop d'intérêt puisque de toute
manière tu vas devoir
de l'appeler après un coup
parce que
si c'est un mois de jouer j'ai un doute
je fais appel là je suis un peu
et voilà
écoute est-ce que est-ce que Google je
peux la tenir sa langue
clairement clairement usageable mais il
a du mal à bouger hein
il y a peut-être de ta mèche parce que
j'ai envie de faire maintenant peut-être
moi pas sortir essayer de
et j'ai quatre rangées 7
e
plein de faiblesses chez les noirs
j'ai du mal à défendre
elle est une 29 contre 2 minutes 17
h 5 kumalin
H6 c'est chèque et après le pion sera en
prise donc mes H6 c'est quand même moche
tu as pas envie de le faire il l'a fait
mais je comprends
mesdames G4 il va revenir ici ce plan il
est faible j'ai peut-être vu alors je
peux pas jouer là il y a toujours
ici Fatou j'ai 8
de nouveau
et là tu bouges plus
et maintenant je vais essayer de partir
mon roi là bas de faire à 5 moi je sais
pas tu vois je sais faire un truc
allez on va
34 secondes à la pendule
et on est au 40e coup donc là les blancs
on leur incrément les Noirs pas encore
presque dès qu'il aura son coup et bien
ils auront une seconde d'incrément mais
jouer avec 20 secondes plus une seconde
d'incrément c'est extrêmement lent
on l'a vu avec ma médias
alors quand même très fort pour
pour caravane aussi
même si la jauge n'aime pas ce que je
fais
il a pris le
ok ça ça peut aider les Noirs en défense
ici
en gamin d'après un pion il est mieux
autant écoute
[Musique]
d'avoir pris le pion et d'être mieux
autant tu es encore active tu as le
droit qui passif à cause du pion du pion
H qui contrôle bien les cases
c'est extrêmement dur en défense elle me
sort ça j'ai ça échec je peux vraiment
tricoter
même mon rejet 4 alors bien je préfère
plutôt que j'ai 4
après je peux plus monter mon actif et
si elle bouge toi je pourrais me faire
ça et faire ça et rentrer quoi peut-être
je comprends que Madame donc j'ai pas
peur
même là peut-être
ça part un peu chaud mais
je mange plus ou quoi
ça m'a l'air un peu un peu chaud
effectivement
avec 53 secondes contre 4 secondes 4
secondes seulement pour Google
donc ça veut pas dire grand chose encore
plus
l'activité déjà
je suis bloqué
je pense qu'il va juste tourner en rond
et à faire des allers-retours avec son
roi en tout cas je vais très vite
tout impôts
il a pas le choix
et tu penses que Fabi il peut se faire
flag
il réfléchit au fur et à mesure
peut-être pas mais est-ce que ça peut
répéter
peut-être malencontreusement
ça
dure rapidement si c'est de demander la
nulle
c'est pas comme sur Internet pas comme
ça quoi
allez par contre à 5 maintenant ça va
pion qui va être faible il va venir
attaquer
mais il a pas le choix il va essayer
d'embrouiller
il embrouille il perd tous les pions
mais il menace des trucs en tout cas en
bas
5 secondes chacun waouh
extrêmement vite ça bug un petit peu là
ça ils vont trop vite je vois pas tout
dans la légitime un petit peu ça peut ça
peut faire nul ça non joue
car voilà qui tombe car voilà qui tombe
allez
prédit j'avais prévu incroyable
incroyable
est-ce que tu penses que tu as une
seconde parcours c'est quasiment rien
sur un vrai chier mais est-ce que c'est
gagnant ça prend le blanc on voit la
chose qui qui parle dans tous les sens
mais en vrai est-ce que c'est gagnant
genre
comment tu gagnes
en fait tu pourras pas ma tête une seule
dame moi je me lasse échec et
le roi et est-ce que tu
peux pas te cacher moi je m'en fous hein
tu manges le pion ici
bien sûr là je vais pas aller en H6 je
suis pas bête
comment tu passes là je fais les
couleurs dit
es
c'est nul
le
d'empêcher ça
en B4
est-ce que tu peux taper une embrouille
je vais ici
non mais c'est nul je pense hein qui
tombe mais si la position est nulle et
que l'Armageddon fait gagner les Noirs
je pense que le c'est pas tu vois c'est
pas grave laisse tomber
on voit ça un peu dramatique il avait
plein de pions de plus hyper content
mais en fait si c'est nul et ben le goût
cache gagne quand même parce qu'il avait
les noirs
et si la police s'en est nulle ben il
aurait quand même perdu en fait et je
vois pas enfin Google
[Musique]
c'est moi qui fait chier quelqu'un
tu dois faire échec pour pas que je
puisse en faire moi-même
allez si on repart sur carvalin
pardon sur Magnus
et furuza alors il y a eu petit rock qui
vient d'être joué c'est marrant le rock
qui est jaune au 20e coup ici
oui on m'a pas pH 6 c'est vrai Alicia en
marre juste acheter
c'est un stress de roquet côté pendule
pour un jeu plus vite
alors ambulette
moi quand je vois en Bullet généralement
je construisais un château à côté de la
pendule
là il faut que je le vide donc tu gagnes
du temps après bon c'est des Bullet les
gens sont professionnels
quand même donc je pense pas que la euse
pour eux sera pas une strate je pense
pas peut-être Naka ça peut être une
personne
il est là pour pour The Flag hein mais
sinon non c'est pas sûr alors on s'est
arrêté là il s'est passé de prise prise
des cinq si on avait dit il a mangé donc
il a rendu son plan de plus
on voit que la position est encore égale
malgré le fait que que
ce soit très très dur à jouer et là il
fait un coup des petits
en fait même si la position
les Noirs vont en jeu comme l'ordi toute
la partie quoi et la moindre erreur peut
être fatale
j'avais dit moi j'avais dit cavalier à 6
pour que ça
avais dans cette position là j'avais dit
que j'en ressors ça j'avais dit ça pour
faire ça ça me ramener le cavalier et il
a fait exactement ce que j'avais dit
tour bien ton B7 je prends la contrôle
de la colonne B soit tu pourras pas la
prendre mais j'imagine qu'à un moment
donné les Noirs vont vouloir faire
peut-être
je pense faire alors soit qu'avec
les jours où tu manges j'ai ben j'ai un
pion passé protéger une belle chaîne de
pion après je pourrais mettre mon
cavalier ici
et tout est faiblesses après je ramène
la tour ici la dame je peux doubler que
mes tours sur la colonne B ça m'a l'air
d'être beaucoup trop dur pour les jours
j'avais pas franchement là je crois
qu'elle est française elle aime bien
elle aime beaucoup ce qui rouvrent mais
moi je bois de français je suis pas
d'accord avec la joie je trouve que
c'est trop dur pour les Noirs c'est
hyper dur pour la barre
et si je prends là j'ai ça à ça ça m'a
l'air dégueulasse quoi faire ça ça c'est
moi qui le prend la colonne B j'ai bien
passé
je vois pas pourquoi
la position est égale en fait
ça
tout le monde sur 15 novembre
dans le meilleur des cas où ce que je
dis coup d'affilée mais du coup sont là
sont présents
et mon plan est facile alors toi il faut
trouver un plan tu veux pas faire ça tu
peux pas faire ça pas doubler en fait
toi et pour venir ici il faut faire
trois coups
ou alors échanger mais si tu échanges
et que tu fais tomber vite et ben écoute
tu as saqué faible tu as 5 qui est
faible c'est trop chaud
j'ai l'impression qu'en fait tu as trop
de problèmes
pourquoi j'ai trop c'est le coup d'ordi
j'ai trop c'est bizarre
[Musique]
la finale elle est très dur il y a tout
plein
peut-être que là j'ai cavalué 7 dessins
et si tu prends tu me laisses un peu
revenir quoi parce que il va falloir
sortir c'est pas la même
je suis pas fans
pas fan du tout d'abord c'est simple
après c'est 5 ce que j'ai pas calculé
c'est ça mais bon j'ai envie de dire que
quand même stofi j'ai mis le 23 j'avoue
je vais sortir un stofish
je te fiche
je pense qu'il faut manger
tu manges C4
à moins que je peux te faire cavaler les
D4 et que tu es pas cavaliers
ça c'est possible et là les tours sont
paralysés un peu pas venir sur la
colonne B donc moi je vais pouvoir faire
ça ça rapidement j'ai un pion de moi
mais j'ai les pièces trop fortes
ton pronostic sur la partie c'est quoi
changer non mais
est-ce que tu penses que je vais faire
une fleur mais mais est-ce que tu penses
est-ce que
tu penses que
tu es bien parti par rapport à ton à ton
pronostic
qui était la nul ici dans cette partie
donc
j'ai envie de croire en la victoire de
Magnus mais
[Musique]
je reste sur la
c'est bien
c'est bien moi je crois pas du tout
la position de yaourt et son choix
d'ouverture
c'est dur
er l'inventivité
encourager la folie
son final non je pense qu'il y en a rien
à
je pense que vraiment firou il va jouer
les meilleurs coups qu'il considère je
pense pas qu'il soit
qui soit comment dire
influencer
à partir du moment il calcule quelque
chose qui pense que c'est bon il va le
jouer peu importe l'adversaire ou
influencé par le niveau de joueurs
un carré prend d'un point fou ton papa
elle tombe pas dans le piège
elle a vu elle a vu Fatou elle a vu le
petit pion passé
elle a vu mon petit piège pourtant
c'était
ça pouvait passer ça pouvait passer
mais
à certains joueurs comme ça on sait que
ça passe
[Musique]
donc ok écoute Magnus je pense qu'il
gagne encore ils ont plus beaucoup de
temps la pendule et restent 26 minutes
contre 23 minutes ils ont fait 23 coups
donc écoute Fatou je pense qu'on va
avoir un petit sprint final très bientôt
si on allait pas ça un peu voir les
parties qui restaient on a saut qui joue
contre Abdou saut il avait une finale
qui avait l'air très très bonne voilà un
peu ce qui se passe là on s'est arrêté à
à l'échange de cavaliers et après ça il
y a eu F6
ça a l'air bizarre ouais je pense plutôt
à jouer on a dit quoi tout à l'heure
on avait dit des trois
pour tourner deux et pour
tout F7 c'est bizarre ça et là il perd
tous les pions et roi F1 et en fait
avant l'option et maintenant j'ai plus
qu'à les cueillir tous les pions qui me
seront donnés parce qu'en fait ce pion
il est perdu aussi par exemple ça je
fais ça je fais ça je fais ça je fais ça
et j'ai trois points de plus
je pense c'est fini la partie d'abdo
elle est terminée voir ce qui va qui va
battre battre
et chez guillitary
et tari
c'était aussi la finale je sais pas trop
dire si ça pouvait gagner ou pas j'ai
envie de j'ai envie de croire que c'est
nul toi
mais je sais pas du tout c'est que deux
tours c'est quand même beaucoup
ah oui non non
mais comment est-ce que je peux ce que
je peux mettre une deuxième tour ici
mais ça suffira pas ma je serai je crois
j'ai 7 et tu attaques enfin tu peux pas
pas du tout ramener une tour
supplémentaire à l'attaque
et à part doubler là quel est ton plan
qui a poussé des pions et essayer
d'échanger des pions mais plus tu
pousses depuis en plus on va se changer
et plus il y a de chance de nul
franchement j'ai pas sûr du tout que
cette position elle puisse gagner
j'ai envie de croire aux chances de noir
Fatou
mais bon peut-être que ça gagne
apparemment le roi
essayez de monter un peu le roi passer
une tour en CV
je sais pas j'essaie de voir des chemins
je cherche même genre ça j'ai toujours
échec je repars
je sais pas
ah oui bien sûr
c'est des trucs c'est pas mal
en partie lente contre le meilleur
joueur du monde
après il peut toujours regarder et il a
pas joué ça il a laissé les cars scène
dans la ce petit pion en C5 et le tour
des 8 qui est assez bizarre j'imagine
qu'il veut passer par là
et après c'est 5 et ben j'ai envie de
dire que c'est très dur il a obtenu la
pression que j'avais que je voulais tu
vois j'ai ça sans et doubler sur la
colonne B ça touche de Paris je te
parier un kebab
[Rires]
le plan qui va être adopté ici par
par
fille ou alors on peut aussi essayer de
voir le truc avec H4 peut-être et des
idées des fois de ramener la dame ici et
je sais pas essayer de de faire des
trucs bizarres quoi peut-être même
prendre le roi et si la tour là et
attaquer avec la tour sur la colonnade
la dame qui va arriver mais bon
franchement
c'est vrai
il a besoin d'ouvrir la position
peut-être qu'à un moment donné si ma
tour part qui va tu vois moi j'ai un
plan de faire ça et de mes touristique
et double sur la colonne B peut-être
qu'un moment il y aura 4 quoi tu vois
j'ai besoin de créer des choses sans
créer des choses et essayer de peut-être
que le tour D8 car je dis ça peut-être
que l'idée c'est ça ça et partir sur la
colère
qu'est-ce qu'on en sait
donc ok mais bon j'y crois pas du tout
c'est genre le truc que je crois pas du
tout je pense que ce qu'il a joué j'ai
trois voilà
salut ciel bleu bien bonsoir à toi
désolé j'étais pas là hier soir quand
vous avez demandé une info de base de
données j'arrive cette partie du stream
en différé et du coup j'attends encore
la réponse je suis encore c'était la
réponse ciel bleu je suis là
j'attends la réponse
c'était quoi la question je t'ai posé je
me suis mais tu me diras quand même mais
ne t'excuse pas pour ça
merci titine on a voilà d'ailleurs on
peut même essayer les autres autres
vous savez qu'on a on a une belle scène
avec regardez
est-ce que vous aimez cette scène si
vous l'aimez bien on peut rester dessus
je sais que c'est pas encore le
diagnotte les gens mais là on les voit
bien
on les voit bien est-ce que
professionnel
je pense pas il y a quand même plus trop
de temps à la banlie je pense qu'à un
moment donné il a envie il a envie de
sa partie quoi
[Musique]
tu parles bah pourtant il y en avait
mais je crois que c'est pas la même
position si elle veut mais il y avait
des ressemblances par rapport à une
fonction que j'ai vu et c'était ding
ding qui avait des blancs et c'était
qui a joué aux candidat j'en suis sûr de
moi et c'est une position où il a
balancé des pions sur le roi ça
ressemblait à un truc pareil si elle
bleu
je suis sûr de moi je suis prêt à parier
un deuxième kebab contre tout
alors ton dessert un
bâtiment entier un bâtiment
4 il y a plus de tomber un Fatou
il y a plus que tourbéen et j'ai gagné
mon petit Paris à plat on voit que tu
sais jouer aux échecs
on voit que on valide on va être au
niveau de jeu comme tout
il attaque les deux pions faibles en E6
C6 aussi F5 des fois il peut y avoir
même regarder si je bouge ma tour bon je
le ferai pas mais des fois plus tard
plus tard en fin de partie ça reste un
thème qui font envisager genre de chose
donc le cavalier il est bien placé il
vise ça ça sent en plus le Caval il
empêche dame de te rendre à parler avec
les visages 4 et c'est d'ouvrir tu vois
qu'elle est monstrueux qu'on voit tous
les chèques tout seul
c'est un génie
un kebab un bâtiment je sais pas au
biberon mais c'est vrai que le bâtiment
ça coûte plus cher quand même
plutôt qu'un kebab OK
[Musique]
le menu
la jauge aime de moins en moins firou et
souffle n'a jamais aimé filou
faisait et la jauge lui donner un petit
peu raison quand même tu vois elle était
pas là j'étais pas très
[Musique]
très critique envers à filou alors quand
j'étais hyper critique j'aimais pas du
tout ce qu'il faisait et là ça se
justifie en fait au final sur le long
terme tu sens bien que la position n'est
pas correcte on sent bien que qu'il y a
plein de problèmes en fait et maintenant
que tu as fait quelques imprécisions et
ben tu sens bien qu'en fait à la
pollution elle est pas bonne du tout
quoi enfin il y a tout qui se casse la
gueule
et salut à toi
tous ceux qui nous ont rejoint depuis un
petit moment
donc du coup
victoire de Carlson qui se profile
beaucoup de points de challenge en jeu
il y en a qui vont pleurer dans le chat
alors Augus qui veut remettre la scène
d'avant
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez bonne
soirée bonne soirée voilà est-ce que
vous voulez tous changer la chaîne
d'avant ou moi je m'en fous mais cela
m'a l'air pas mal mais après je demande
juste une bonne soirée malin peut-être
on peut faire
comme ça en fait il y a des gens qui
arrivent pas à voir sur un vrai
Shaquille il y a des gens qui sont
il y a des gens qui sont qui sont qui
font des échecs quasiment que online et
qui ont besoin d'avoir ce qu'il y a à
droite
c'est pas du tout la même
et pas à l'autre et on se trouve un
petit peu perdu donc c'est pour ça qu'on
offre la possibilité
un petit peu à tout le monde de suivre
après si vous voulez je mets la photo de
Fatou sur la tête de
tu mets tu te mets sur le cancer
moi je suis française monsieur
jusqu'au bout on y croit je viens de
quoi
en plus on a la même couleur de cheveux
pas très bien donc
le faut nous mettre sur les on effigie
sur leur
canette canette d'eau
c'est bizarre de dire ça
les cases
ça c'est très drôle
et ciel bleu missionné par toi qui
continue de chercher je vous ai mis les
caméras voilà des bricolages
vous vouliez absolument nous voir
[Musique]
est-ce que tu peux partir du champ et
les Sénat
elle est partie manger
il y a trop de trucs
tout petit j'avoue tu mets tu mets le
char en gros mais une alarme grand si
vous voulez je la mets en vidéo si vous
voulez en couple aussi on part sur un
stream sur un stream canin
pourquoi pas
et tu vois avec la vue d'ici quand tu
vois le
l'espace des blancs
là tu te dis enfin réfléchiquier 3D tu
as vraiment l'impression que c'est un
massacre je sais que c'est les chiens
excuse-moi c'est des canards je m'en
suis rendu compte après Titi de c'est
vrai je suis
désolé mais
on s'est compris c'est le principal
oui c'est vrai moi je pense que sur un
vrai chez qui on sent plus compte de la
supériorité de la position de l'anus ici
avec
l'espace tu vois et toutes les cases
blanches qui sont contrôlées
carrément
comme ton pseudo heureusement ça se voit
pas trop à la caméra
tomber de la table 2 on va aller voir un
tableau de ce qui s'est passé
tableau de
on a ici avec ce contre abdoué
donc là il y aura pas d'Armageddon pour
eux
guéri est-ce que ça peut ça se
transforme
c'est pas simple mais j'ai pensé à une
idée peut-être de faire ça et ça c'est
mettre le roi un petit peu en réseau tu
vois après ample tour ici
j'étais parti pour pour cibler H7 mais
effectivement si tu gardes le 7 on a du
mal
essayer de passer
G4 et H4 un truc comme ça et il y a des
réseaux de maths quand même c'est vrai
que
à égalité de pions ce serait nul facile
je pense
mais là quatre contre trois
[Musique]
ok retourne sur Magnus quand même c'est
la partie qui nous intéresse je pense
c'est là je pense qu'on aura le temps de
voir la fin parce que ça va tourner un
petit peu
pour l'instant qui est gagnant
ben Magnus
pour l'avantage quand même
je pense faire un moment que je dis
qu'il a un gros avantage
il prend l'avance autant aussi au bon
moment donc
là
ça va être compliqué
compliqué pour l'autre petit français
pour avoir 10 secondes d'incrément ce
qui est rien donc en fait
filou il est vraiment en gros
qui a commencé à je reviens
un bon concept
S
je sais pas c'est faux mais il y avait
un
tromper c'est le bleu comme trompé
ça arrive des fois
ça arrive
avec déjà deux joueurs qui sont tombés
aujourd'hui
c'est pas rien
mais bon entre entre filles ou qui joue
en Bullet et Magnus qui joue en l'an
enfin il y a pas photo quoi donc non
là il est en grand danger la pollution
elle pue il est mal au temps enfin il y
a rien qui va à la position de finir au
moins c'est 100% qui parle
tour bien et oui tour bien et c'est le
coup pour le kebab Fatou le coup du
kebab je te mets en grand en fait juste
pour qu'il voit bien
tu vois faut bien jouer tant bien elle
va prendre la tour tu as intérêt à être
en B1 RIP
c'est pas le moment
elle est
je vais me mettre
je vais vous mettre la
tu as 1801 je crois non
Fatou qui est parti en B1 et voilà
du coup j'ai gagné un bâtiment où j'ai
gagné où j'ai gagné un kebab et j'ai
gagné un truc Fatou
et H4 a été joué
mais tu as gagné ton bâtiment à kebab au
chorizo
[Musique]
et donc bien sûr il va pas changer la
dame il faut qu'il joue actif
ça
fait peur quand même
et ils sont dans ma cadre comment est-ce
qu'on joue retomber trois restes une
idée
en fait il y a aucune menace
chez les chez les noirs
par exemple
sur la carte
et
ESH que tout est trop bien quoi
il y a pas de mauvais coup pour les
blancs alors que les Noirs chaque jour à
faire ça va
[Musique]
ça va
faut que j'arrête à tout jusqu'au bout
il t'écoute faut que j'arrête ouais
[Musique]
5 mais à 5 fois la dame elle a plus de
15 ans
elle est pas enfermée
mais elle est pas elle est pas perdue en
tout cas elle est pas
ça fait un moment déjà que la position
elle pue la position ça fait un moment
que ça a pas du tout
et moi c'est depuis le début que je vous
le dis
depuis le début je vous le dis
c'est pas de maintenant
depuis le début je dis pas ça va être
l'ambiance il faut y avoir des choses
mais je croyais pas du tout en sachant
depuis le début
je pensais que c'était pas une bonne
idée de faire ça contre Magnus Magnus
qui est en phase de gagner sa première
partie d'événement
c'est les fruits du bien un peu en moral
aussi à ma gousse c'est dommage ça se
passe contre notre français c'est clair
mais après on peut pas les reprocher à
faire ou de vouloir gagner de prendre
des risques c'est clair que c'est un
truc qu'on aime bien
on aime jouer
c'est pas mieux que de le battre
non mais il a il a créé un peu le buzz
aussi avec son ouverture marrante
et bon
attendez si ça va être joué
bon peut-être qu'il a pris l'esprit
histoire
mais bon je vois pas comment t'activer
je vais pousser mon pied
tu vois pas ce que tu peux faire avec
les mecs
[Musique]
mais bon je mangerai mais j'aurais de la
rupture avancer ça c'est une position
qui est quasiment enfin qui est déjà
abandonnable je pense
je pense je vois pas comment on dit des
fois en fait
tu peux encore défendre mais c'est ça
[Musique]
c'est trop dur
je pense que c'est déjà trop dur pour
ici n'est pas Caruana candidats
je me souviens plus si elle veut mais
t'inquiète pas arrête de
en fait peut-être que je me trompe de
tournoi peut-être que je me trompe de
truc
je pourrais chercher moi éventuellement
je te redirai
mais laquelle des parties me faisait
penser à la partie d'hier
afin de te dire je pourrais
[Musique]
je pourrais regarder moi-même parce que
là je sais même pas je sais plus de quoi
je parle en plus je me sens même plus de
la partie d'hier
donc à 5 ouais bon bah tant baisser ça
je pensais
un peu tragiquement il avait plusieurs
pions de plus
il sera interpelle ces moments il a
il est tombé autant
alors que guéri fait le plan qu'on avait
posé que j'ai quatre H4 et il va menacer
de passer par derrière avec la toit je
pense que guéri va gagner aussi le
quartier il va gagner aussi
ça avance un petit peu plus qu'ici
à la place
ça évite de changer de scène comme ça
vous avez deux parties en même temps et
il vient de jouer ici
[Musique]
et là il prépare peut-être un tour à
vide pour jouer tout ici et là il faut
voir s'il y a pas de réseau de maths
je peux aussi faire F4 je pense c'est
une question qui est difficile pour
merci
il faut être rapide dans ces cas-là
tourner
[Musique]
sur protection Magnus
le fou et le cabas de sureau ne foutent
rien
c'est un peu ça les gars
pas si
que les pièces passées ce qui va arriver
je vais manger là
c'est juste trop dur pour les blancs
aussi
est-ce qu'on peut
la menace de Magnus
ouais très bien d'accord je pense que
c'est peut-être la menace tout à l'heure
et avoir cette finale qui est juste
gagné en temps j'ai trop de jeux par
rapport à mes pièces la seule pièce
active des noirs
pour échanger et après à 5 tours D1
défend cavaliers tel que maintenant il
veut libérer la dame pour venir en B3
sans perdre et après ça les Noirs
pourront pas du tout empêcher
[Musique]
la finale
est-ce que tu penses que firou il va
faire son propre F4
est-ce que tu penses qu'il va
en fait j'ai envie de dire que tu es
foutu quoi
après c'est vrai que si il a pas voulu
changer s'il a pas essayé de ramener ses
pièces de l'autre côté
ça je pense c'est fini
ça ça en fait il y a tout qui tombe là
c'est dominant
il y a tout qui tombe
la seule chance de firou peut-être ça te
dirait là on y va quoi
c'est pardon c'est sûr
mais tu vois je vais faire échelle je
vais faire F4
boom
[Musique]
ça paraît logique parce que soit tu
abandonnes toi tu fais ça quoi
tout refait un et pour tout ça
il aurait pu faire
pour baisser
de faire en sorte que que tu puisses
jamais sacrifier en fait tu gardes là
et bien
voilà c'est gagnant assez je pense
tranquille je pense dame B3 va jouer
et tu dois changer les dames pas le
choix et chacun
jouer c'est la partie
et après l'échec
on risque d'avoir un cavalier qui va
bouger parce que F4 F3 G3 enfin il y a
un petit peu de jeu mais bon et Fillon
qui est très mal de temps sur toi qui a
5 minutes à la pendule pour jouer pour
jouer 8 coups cette coupe pardon
tu as échec
un peu de jeu ça va gagner hein bien sûr
mais bon
c'est cool carrément
pourquoi
et maintenant bah écoute ça va être trop
fort le trop fort dès que tu
perds à lui je le prends je reviens je
pousse le pioncer
la troisième rangée oui non ça a l'air
perdu
es
pour défendre le pion
des tours
là
tu as trop de problèmes en fait ma
position
ça va pas du tout
ça va absolument pas
les raisins
continue un grain de la même position
qu'avant je crois qu'il y a pas eu de
coup hein depuis
[Musique]
je pense que on va pas
partir qui vont se terminer par 1 0
toutes les deux
mais bon tout gagne moi je mange là
attention tu peux avoir un peu quelques
frayeurs quand même
enfin je vais faire ça ça
vraiment rien du tout
je suis persuadé qu'il y a rien
peu de temps la pendule fioul qui lui
reste 3 minutes à jouer 3 minutes pour
jouer 7 coups après il a le temps encore
vous savez que que un blitz qu'on fait
tranquille à la maison en 3 + 0 on peut
faire plein de coups donc là cette coup
à jouer il va aller faire mais après
cette coupe il a encore
seulement 10 secondes parcours
d'incrément elle en a pas pour la
première
en dessous de 5 minutes
quand on a en ajoutant
de 10 secondes seulement on peut moins
de 30 secondes mais pas obligé de noter
donc là il continue mais c'est une perte
de temps
après il y a des joueurs qui préfèrent
compter jusqu'au
moins de 5 minutes à la pendule tu peux
arrêter c'est pas obligé mais tu peux
arrêter
donc A4 oui l'idée la carte
la défense
des pions et du cavalier
donc
là soit tu gardes la tour sur la 3e soit
tu la mets en B6 pour aller manger ses 6
mais je suis pas sûr que tu aies besoin
de la tour pour aller manger ces 6 je
pense un coup comme comme pour C3 ou 3
ou
3 peut-être pas sûr après ça dépend
parce que là j'ai vu dans le chat on a
si elle bleu qui a dit que sur cavalier
H3 on pouvait peut-être faire tout
reprendre H3 et apparemment ça tuait le
contre jeu tu vois je vais faire ça il y
a tout qui tombe en fait chez les chez
les Noirs j'ai quand même deux pièces
pour la tour plus le point qui va tomber
pour ça ça a l'air dramatique donc comme
ça ça va marcher
comme ça ça a l'air de marcher peut-être
juste la tour n'importe où
dès qu'il fait ça je prends en fait
tu vas aller où tu veux
je vais manger là quand tu manges là et
que tu manges là je mangerai là même pas
encore mieux
en fait c'est pour la tour et trop de
quoi
et sur ça je fais ça
non
on a du mal
tu les trois ouais bah il y a un peu de
jeu Alicia mais bon normalement j'ai
quand même excusé d'avoir une pièce pour
défendre moi mon plan c'est bouger ma
tour ah tiens il va en P4
c'est de bouger la tour de manger là de
revenir et de pousser mon pion c'est mon
plan
allez courage 7 je vais par
les raisins
et il va tout faire pour attaquer
donc a priori j'attaque là en plus
ça a forcé de bouger
et d'ailleurs
tu vois je me barre un peu
je pense que j'ai envie d'aller en F1 tu
vois ici
pour pour que tu fasses ça en fait
[Musique]
que je peux alors
quand même de tout perdre
Fatou je crois que c'est fini
je crois que c'est fini
il va se battre encore un petit peu mais
c'est pourquoi on n'y croit plus
il prend son temps
là
il a fait une partie d'alcoolique et
comme il est très bon en alcoolique
non pour pour
répéter mais
non la partie au début non c'était une
partie intéressante en vrai il a raté
des trucs après bon moi je vais regarder
avec la joie donc mais à la fin un bet
final auto non je pense que c'est pas
une si mauvaise partie que la fleur du
battre Eliot
et 4 sur 5 quoi il a battu hier
avant un autre maître encore
ce qui fait un bon tournoi pour
l'instant
ça s'annonce pas bien du tout bah c'est
lui qui joue là il est très très mal
contre ma muse
Tour Eiffel a été joué en direct
qui est pas qui qui a gagné
5 peut-être de toute façon
est extrêmement dur
extrêmement
on a bien envie de pousser mais
[Musique]
rapide
je veux pas me faire mater de faire un
truc tout bête tu vois même là cavalier
3 il y a rien mais tu vois je peux même
claquer en fait la qualité quand je veux
ça montre à quel point la pollution elle
est perdante quoi tu vois
si tu vois qu'à tout moment tu peux
sacrifier la qualité et être gagnant en
fait
une minute trente à jouer il reste plus
que trois coups à jouer pour pour
trois coups 250
et après il aura 10 secondes dans 40e
coup là il vient de 4 qui est le 38e
voilà la partie position est trop dur
allez bouge et tu pousses
si je veux
enfin c'est perdu quoi
enfin toute l'accord je suis d'accord
je fais tout ce que je veux la déception
sur mon visage
il y a aucune menace il y a rien qui va
avancer
même cavalier
en fait c'est une position où tu veux
pas calculer parce que tu veux pas te
prendre la tête tu veux être sûr de
gagner et en fait plus tu calcules tu
peux te tromper donc des fois quand tu
joues des couples solides ou toutes les
fendu et ben tu as pas besoin de
calculer en fait et c'est ce qu'on
recherche
la deuxième partie
est encore
est encore joueuse un peu ça bouge un
peu mais bon c'est très difficile pour
pour Paris
qui va je pense qu'il va faire en fait
est-ce qu'on y fait un petit tour ou pas
je peux te la montrer ici si tu veux
40 contre 3 minutes chez Ariane tari ils
sont au
40ème coup après F5 donc ils ont un
incrément dans 4 27 contre 3 minutes il
y a un incrément et il y a du G5 qui va
arriver
et un truc comme ça par exemple ça ça va
être dur à défendre
peut-être ça
ça sent le mal de partout
la mousse qui prend son temps pour finir
la partie
et peut-être qu'il a envie d'arrêter de
noter
moi je me souviens il y avait il y a
très longtemps
j'imagine c'était une cadence 50 + 10 je
crois il y a vraiment le temps ou d'une
heure chaos je crois et je te gêne et il
y avait un joueur qui avait plus de
temps la pendule qui avait genre je sais
pas trois minutes
il y a un autre
donc le mecs
et les joueurs qui avaient je sais pas
encore 20 minutes à la pendule c'était
un jour à 2150
et le 21 50 il était gagnant mais
l'autre en fait l'autre tout est un peu
tout le temps il arrivait pas à
faire tomber ou quoi
en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que le
21 50 il est parti pendant un café
pendant un quart d'heure
et quand il est revenu la ça pour
arrêter de noter et il a gagné voilà
donc la République pour le fait d'avoir
un quart d'heure pourtant c'est cool on
en a marre de voter
rèse tu sais l'autre etc et du coup
c'est il savait que
engendre du tempo de tempo c'était ça
allait tout vite mais bon c'est quand
même dommage de perdre tout son temps
bêtement tu vois
d'utiliser un peu mieux
mais je m'en souviens ce souvenir moi
tu peux aussi faire ça maintenant il y a
tout qui tombe
bouge la tour tu perds là tu perds la
barrière
le cavalier tient tout quand même
mais attention que c'est peut-être
trompé un petit peu là
est-ce qu'il aurait pas oublié pour
cette fois par hasard à Magnus
parce que à Tours C3 c'est 7 ça reste
hyper dur à jouer pour
pour aller raisin mais
il a quand même des pions
la cavalier fou quand même pour la tour
il y a des pions noirs quand même
il y a un plan
et des pièces qui bougent plus parce que
le cavalier va être à la défense ici et
ce qui me fait peur aussi c'est ça sans
dans le sens aussi cavalier bouge ou si
je défends
du F4 et là un peu de contrôle de quand
même dès qu'il bouge à ça ça me fait un
peu peur
de jouer OK
donc 41e à 41 secondes plus 10 secondes
par coup
et Magnus 4 minutes plus des zones
parcours là c'est un ultra bersart
peut-être
mais moi je vois la tour C3
c'est pas si clair je pense que je pense
que malgré
il y a tellement voulu
jouer simple et pas donner de jeu qu'il
a fini par un par ordre mais
là c'est vrai que ça avait l'air
j'aurais pas mangé cette liste là
j'avais dit quoi moi j'aurais fait tout
reprendre je crois je regarde le thé
maton sur la 3e
et là ça j'aurais fait ça je vois pas
comment il attaque qu'est-ce qu'il fait
à la jauge je dis ça
mais bon c'est la même sang que je donne
le cavalier non c'est quoi le problème
ok bon ça reste chaud ça reste très
chaud
Magnus il va pas être content je pense
de son choix
on la défaveur de
c'est un très bon blitzer c'est un très
bon bulleter bien sûr que il y a le
stress il y a plein de choses
mais
[Musique]
donc avoir moins de temps c'est clair
c'est un problème mais
il peut s'en sortir quoi il a jamais
aussi bien que maintenant en fait elle
je pensais pas je pensais pas que
je jouais comme ça en vrai ma muscade
c'est deux
mais si j'arrive à faire ça et ça j'aime
bien plus à la fin il y a quand même des
pions chez les Noirs donc faut voir qui
avait les D8 ok qu'est-ce qu'il veut
faire il veut manger aussi
attention attention attention attention
je sais pas comment ça se joue
il faut il faut manger je pense
pas trop le choix 2 minutes en tout 40
secondes
même là on voit tant pis il dit - 2 bon
mais avec peu de temps la pendule c'est
c'est hyper compliqué cette pollution
hyper compliqué tout se passe encore
Magnus peut gagner comme peu perdre
par contre si ma venue enfin s'ils font
nuls et qu'il y a un magasin Magnus il
va jamais gagner
il serait trop tilté je pense tellement
gagnant ici que
parfois
cavalier prend ça peut être chaud ce
soir
foulard ça empêche ça
un peu pratique
ça va être trop dur
il
va la perdre incroyable
incroyable
Margus qui est foutu
c'est magnifique
c'est vraiment beaucoup de mal à
accepter le fait que Maggie est raté
cette partie enfin cette fin de partie
ce qui est tellement écrasant l'avantage
qu'il avait tellement écrasé
et vous êtes 5 je fais F2 si tu prends
je fais tourner échec et je fais un tour
ici je m'empêche la dame
sur ça
par exemple
ça j'ai encore
OK
apparemment c'est pas le bon coup là
il aurait fallu faire un deux
apparemment
de d'aller résa ici et vous deux je fais
dames dames et là j'ai plein d'échecs
qui maquille en fait
après pas toujours revenir et chaque roi
là faire F2
après il peut toujours faire un chèque
et revenir ici
ça peut faire mieux dans les joueurs qui
ont l'air de répéter
ils ont fait nul incroyable ça a fait
des magasins et je vais vous montrer un
truc
c'est incroyable Magnus qui était à
trois coups de perdre
je crois
ah non
je me disais que c'était gagnant on
m'annonce plus de 44 avec F2 et une fois
que je joue ici
G3
si je mange la dame
ah c'est hyper chiant c'est hyper
compliqué
mais Magnus à quand même bien
en fin de partie parce que ici
dans cette position déjà avant un 4
il faut qu'il arrive à vraiment enlever
le contrôle je crois donc un truc comme
tout droit par exemple en fait dès que
tu mets le Cavalaire
et ça m'a l'air ça m'a l'air très fort
plein de il y avait plein de manières
d'annuler mais en fait c'est un problème
quand tu es tellement gagnant des fois
que
que tu sais plus comment gagner tu as
trop de possibilités il y a trop de
trucs et au final ça devient trop dur
tiens pas tu regardes l'arbitre c'est
toi
a du mal à suivre comme disait le chat
donc c'est impressionnant
[Musique]
ici j'avais vu bon ça marche pas je
crois
mais
hop F2
ça marche pas ça
comme ça ça marche comme ça ok je
m'étais arrêté à je m'étais arrêté à
cavaler la jolie ce matin
une jolie
très jolie
mais ok donc on va voir quand même un
Armageddon entre entre Magnus et
Ali raisin alors que diri a gagné la
partie est-ce que vous voulez qu'on
regarde qu'on voit comment guérir a
gagné sa partie
si vous voulez parce que j'ai pas encore
la nouvelle de à quelle heure va être
l'Armageddon de Magnus
mais alors attends
alors ça
j'ai 5 ans
ici hop prise pour apprendre tous les 5
là tous les plans qui vont tomber en
fait
on pousse on fait ça ouais c'est fini en
je vais faire ça ça et en fait je vais
manger les pions
c'est fini en fait
ouais donc en fait
Guéret qui a gagné la partie on fait un
petit point si vous voulez un petit
point résultat
avant de voir l'Armageddon alors pour un
résultat je vais vous les montrer ici
on a Marc giscards qui vont faire un
super spectacle depuis le début qui vont
se retrouver en arnaque et dans
l'instant on a so qui a battu un petit
Rohff
en classique Cooke qui a battu karwana
en Armageddon
Ikaru qui a battu ma mère en Armageddon
et anus qui a battu Paris en classique
pour les standings vous avez pour
l'instant c'est professionnel cette
position avec Ali resa et Magnus qui
vont jouer pour
un point et demi
donc là pour l'instant les raisins
plus un demi point peut-être
pour un des joueurs donc Carona il a
14,5
devant c'est 3 américains en tête
et les Américains
et on a la réponse c'est 21h20
l'Armageddon de Magnus contre Ali raisin
21h20 on a 12 minutes à attendre pour
avoir magazon alors j'ai eu Fatou
quelques petites
confessions ou
interview est-ce que vous voulez qu'on
les qu'on les voit
bien sûr j'ai Google avec échecs
et je Wesley aussi alors on va essayer
de mettre ça là
et il y a aussi l'Inter de 45 que je
viens de recevoir avant ma guidon mais
je j'espère que c'est enfin je pense que
ça va être en
je pense que ça va être en
en norvégien attendez je vais commencer
à télécharger mes petits trucs on a un
peu de temps pour devant nous donc je
vais vous montrer les les
Armageddon qu'on a enfin les
interviews tant qu'on est là
moi je prends tout et malus il fait il
fait la tronche
il est pas content du tout de lui et
compréhensible il avait une position
écrasante
alors
on va commencer si vous voulez avec ma
glue on va voir si c'est en Norvège je
viens ou pas je pense que oui
mais on va quand même partir là dessus
ok c'était rapide
je pense qu'on peut traduire
j'ai pas eu le temps d'entendre
tellement c'était rapide
ils vont demander
le demander ce qui s'est passé un truc
comme ça
c'est bon il y a eu trois mots chacun et
il a rigolé dans le sens que
mais il est pas content
de Magnus
donc du coup j'ai deux interviews de une
du bocage une de saut donc je vais vous
les mettre pendant qu'on attend
l'Armageddon de Magnus à lireza
c'est parti
[Musique]
alors que s'est-il passé avec notre ami
Google
c'était marrant au début parce qu'on
voit que
goes qui a flagorn alors qu'il était
très très mal au temps et donc il a
rigolé et après
ils lui ont demandé
[Musique]
comme question
à la fin du mois ce qui était content
d'être là etc par rapport à cet
événement ce qui pensait l'événement il
disait très bien organisé qui était très
content c'est très prestigieux et que il
faisait un bon tournant en plus il
jouait bien donc j'étais vraiment
content donc la partie ce n'est pas
partie difficile il avait une potion
très difficile à tenir très peu de temps
mais c'est coûtait facile parce que
c'était toujours un roi achète pour la
G7 et
et puis voilà quoi donc c'est pas le
gamin de 14 ans il a pas 14 ans il a 17
ans il vient d'avoir 17 ans
et il a encore tout jeune et puis il a
occasion c'est juste un monstre voilà
donc un petit peu
même tu sens qu'il est un petit peu
stressé qu'il a moins d'expérience tu
vois quand tu as un Magnus car ou enfin
qui parle eux ils ont l'habitude lui il
est un petit peu il est un petit peu de
bac
en tout cas moi je les côtoyer en équipe
en Top 12 il y a quelques années
et franchement il est très très sympa
hyper accessible en plus c'est c'est
très très gentil en tout cas ce petit
bouquet j'ai encore
une interview vous montrer celle de saut
et alors donc je vous la montre tout de
suite
je la recharger je crois que je l'ai pas
prise
d'avoir fait mais j'étais pas dû le
faire bien je pense plus comment
s'appelle
je vais vous la présenter de suite
et elle est là à tout de suite
[Musique]
alors la partie qui a commencé la partie
de de l'Armageddon qui a commencé donc
je peux vous traduire si vous voulez ce
qui s'est passé enfin ce qu'il a parlé
il a beaucoup parlé
sauf dans une interview ils l'ont
demandé déjà
[Musique]
ensuite il a parlé de Norvège et qu'il
adore ce tournoi il adore le lieu il
adore tout ça et que demain si votre
peau mais après demain il va je contrôle
carwana et il espère
faire une grosse partie en tout cas
c'est pour lui c'est une partie
importante parce que le numéro 1 etc
donc
donc voilà pS J'ai pas du tout la partie
qui a mal tourné ça arrive à tout le
monde mais mais oui ça va être voilà
dans tous les cas bon c'était marrant ça
et il a beaucoup parlé mais voilà il
crée entier sur aussi il a un peu des
fois c'est un peu spécial mais mais
c'est quand même quelqu'un de gentil
voilà donc là on a la partie
d'Armageddon sera la dernière partie de
la journée avec Magnus qui a 8 minutes
contre 5 30 maintenant donc on a
commencé avec digne pour les blancs
contre 7 et obligations de gagner pour
les blancs
donc allez résa qui choisit un début
très solide
pour essayer de faire nul je vous
rappelle que
le coup de
la journée je crois
sortir
on change de cavalier et donc c'est la
position qui sont quand même assez
symétiques de base mais là maintenant il
a réussi à changer
la structure tu vois en prenant
j'aime bien les blancs
j'aime bien les blancs mais je sais pas
si ça va suffire attends je vais aller
allumer la lumière
je t'en prie donc
des échecs une bonne question
il y a plein de monde qu'on pourrait
citer après quelqu'un de célèbre pour ça
je
saurais pas
jeffer
[Musique]
il y a tellement de joueurs qui ragent
c'est plus sur internet
un jour qui rage beaucoup c'est un
joueur qui rage beaucoup c'est quand
même aussi c'est quand même aussi
comment il s'appelle
il est un peu moins fort mais
d'ailleurs je l'ai appris à pas
longtemps que c'est comme parce qu'il a
insulté les gens
et oui mais bon c'est standard c'est un
TOP grand maître mais apparemment
insultes répété
mais donc oui mais lui c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment un peu excessif
la douche OK
on demande tu rajoutes à la capture
d'écran du petit déjeuner je sais pas si
c'est faisable techniquement pour toi
[Musique]
ça se passe plutôt bien pour les blancs
il y a déjà des petites faiblesses sur
les chez les noirs
encore un fou
un fou noir qui qui joue pas vraiment
on peut imaginer plus tard peut-être un
cavalier prend des 6
attention quand même un petit peu au
vis-à-vis sur la colonne B1 ça peut être
ça peut être difficile
mais
bel avantage un bel avantage blanc dans
cette position
pouvait peut-être rater son
danse vu la partie qu'il a raté en
partie classique il est tellement
gagnant il a pas gagné que je me disais
que peut-être que ça allait mal tourner
mais qu'il allait du coup
quand tu es gagnant dans ta partie
complètement gagnant quoi et que tu
gagnes pas qu'après finalement bah tu
joues un but derrière l'Armageddon on va
le moral quand même il a il en prend un
peu un coup
et donc
tu vois moi par exemple je serais un peu
dévasté
j'ai une partie que je fais ton gagnant
et finalement
finalement de ne pas
je pense qu'un joueur un joueur enfin
surtout lui
il s'arrête pas à ça
il arrive à passer au-delà de tout
et là il joue à fond il a du temps
d'avance il garde son temps d'avance il
y en a encore plus que au départ non
prise mais il y avait l'autre dame aussi
en prison
quand même ça va être important de la
bouger
et
qu'est-ce qu'on fait là peut-être
traîner mais je veux quand même garder
contrôle de du pion B2
elle lui résa ouais c'est vrai qu'elle a
du raisin il faut des positions il peut
attaquer il peut être actif et là il a
une position très solide contre Magnus
mais au final ça s'est mal
[Musique]
ça a mal tourné et puis maintenant bah
il est passif et c'est vrai dans les
positions
et à Magnus Marie c'est un genre
vraiment universel surtout très très bon
dans les positions tranquilles aussi
donc faux E4 attaque le plan des cinq
qu'est-ce qu'on joue la Fatou est-ce
qu'on va manger
aussi
dans ma carte attention
alors il s'active
parce qu'il a bien tout à l'heure il a
réussi à embrouiller Magnus dans la
partie de classique qui était
complètement foutu et il a réussi à
embrouiller Magnus donc maintenant c'est
ce qui va essayer peut-être de refaire
il a mangé à deux il y a des sacs qui
peut tomber aussi
faire attention mais je peux aussi à
Satis je prends un set je perds je pars
de 5 et là il a mangé ici au 5
donc
plus pour l'instant et six morceaux qui
va échanger et manger à 7 manger ici
est-ce que j'ai pas une idée de
d'apprendre d'un prof il faut prendre et
fou et 4 un truc du style là
[Musique]
j'ai pas compris
les gens je crois qu'on est fatigué en
fait on est fatigué je crois
effectivement la dame excusez-moi on est
en fin de streamer
7 alors si tu mets en dessin et ben je
fais ça ça et c'est perdu
et si tu joues pas ça et ben il faut
défendre le cavalier si tu le défends
[Musique]
qui a fait un peu une non partie mais
c'est vrai que les joueurs ils viennent
d'enchaîner 4h30 de partir lente ou 100
% dans tous les états tous les deux et
pour derrière faire un Armageddon mais
les joueurs sont hyper fatigués donc on
peut comprendre que il y ait des erreurs
comme ça en fin de partie quoi
voilà donc est-ce qu'on fait un dernier
petit point classement enfin tout avant
de vous laisser pour aujourd'hui alors
ça a pas changé beaucoup on a juste la
différence on va revoir un Porcher qui a
qui viennent d'arriver et la prédiction
est-ce qu'il y a un modérateur
j'avais dit quoi déjà
on va voir combien je vais recevoir je
pense que des miettes
des grosses miettes un petit croûton
[Musique]
merci beaucoup charpentier et je suis à
160 maintenant j'ai gagné 40 000
bah ça va j'ai parlé 120 quoi super
pour la prédit charpentier
ouais et donc demain Fatou demain et ben
nous ne sommes pas là parce que demain
ce genre de repos pour les joueurs et
aussi pour les commentateurs donc nous
on se retrouve à partir de jeudi à
partir de 17h pour la rendre du 8 il
reste parti enfin tu restes à la
conduite et la ronde 9
tout à fait et le petit poussin oriente
des gens pour l'encourager dans le chat
c'est pas grave c'est fini dernier il
part il part de loin déjà donc il va
beaucoup apprendre je pense c'est une
expérience énorme pour lui
mais en plus il est même content d'être
là en fait c'est un tournoi pour lui qui
est il joue contre tous les meilleurs
joueurs du monde c'est c'est une grosse
opportunité il est très content d'être
là et
voilà donc puis en plus il y a plein de
notes
priori ça va et Pikachu Alicia
sur la chaîne de stouf sur ma chaîne
éventuellement sur sa chaîne
pour ceux qui ne la connaissent pas
c'est tout vous allez voir c'est simple
mais sur ce come fr peut-être pas quand
même on va être un peu plus sage merci
pour le pour le saut enfin tout pour
ceux qui voudraient me suivre en stream
derrière une fois que votre terminé ou
même aussi apprendre des choses par
rapport à YouTube vous avez la chaîne
Youtube c'est tout et ma chaîne twitch
c'est ouf aussi c'est souffle de partout
c'est stouf partout voilà voilà Fatou
bah écoutez
très bonne soirée à vous tous et merci
beaucoup d'avoir suivi le stream
merci Fatou on va encore accompagné et
puis et puis bah écoute à bientôt prenez
soin de vous reposez-vous bien et puis
d'attaque jeudi pour la suite de
l'événement
allez ciao
bonne soirée